la puissance du président lonjour retenu
par une réunion près du président du
Sénat revient de d'introduire cette
réunion donc Monsieur le Directeur
Général mes chers collègues le premier
point à l'ordre du jour de notre
commission c'est l'édition de Monsieur
Stanislas Bouron donc nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir qui assure la
direction de l'agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires depuis bientôt
6 mois
donc Monsieur le Directeur général nous
avons entendu en novembre dernier dans
le cadre de votre nomination au titre de
l'article 13 de la Constitution à cette
occasion à la demande de notre collègue
le sénateur Fabien Genet rapporteur pour
la commission vous aviez dressé un bilan
de la NCT durant ces trois premières
années d'existence depuis novembre
dernier le Sénat a poursuivi son travail
d'évaluation de l'action de l'agence
puisque la délégation au collectivités
territoriales a publié en février
dernier rapport portant sur le bilan de
la NCT dont je salue les auteurs
j'aperçois Céline Brulin et je pense que
Charles gainer va nous rejoindre dans ce
rapport la délégation dresse un bilan
plus que mitigé de l'action de l'agence
la NCT est peu et mal connue des élus
locaux qui peinent à comprendre son
fonctionnement et ses dispositifs
les élus locaux déplorent l'implication
inégale et partiel des préfets dans la
déclinaison territoriale de l'agence et
enfin comme notre commission l'avait
aussi souligné en novembre au cours de
votre audition la NCT qui a évocation à
devenir un guichet unique pareil pour
les élus une nouvelle strat
les élus regrettent également
l'insuffisance et la complexité du
financement des programmes actions coeur
de ville et petite ville de demain ainsi
dans le cadre de ces dispositifs la part
des subventions versées à diminuer entre
2018 et 2021 la majorité des aides
délivrées prennent en réalité la forme
de prêt de prise de participation et
d'aide au bailleur privé donc ces
critiques je suis directeur vous semble
telle fondée partagez-vous le constat de
ce bilan effectué par la délégation
collectivité territoriale si ce n'est
pas le cas quel bilan dressez-vous des
trois premières années d'existence de
l'agence
dans un deuxième temps après avoir
dressé cet état les lieux notre
commission connaître votre position sur
les perspectives de l'agence alors
qu'une deuxième feuille de route
gouvernementale pour la période
2023 2026 est en cours de finalisation
la ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité Dominique Faure a récemment
détaillé les quatre axes qui devraient
inspirer les grandes orientations de la
feuille de route renforcer
l'accompagnement sur mesure des
territoires renforcer les interventions
avec les partenaires publics de la NCT
améliorer la lisibilité de ces
interventions et enfin développer de
nouveaux champs d'action qui peuvent
être précisés lors d'une future
intervention prévue pour le mois de
juillet en tant que directeur général et
au terme de six mois d'expérience à
votre poste vous disposez d'une bonne
compréhension des enjeux selon vous que
doit contenir cette nouvelle feuille de
route êtes-vous favorable à ce que cette
seconde feuille de route s'inscrive dans
la continuité de la première afin
d'éviter une rupture au milieu de mandat
des élus municipaux ou appelez-vous de
vos vœux au contraire une nouvelle
impulsion pour la NCT
enfin je profite de l'occasion pour vous
interpeller sur un sujet qui nous tient
à cœur au Sénat savoir le contrôle de
l'application des lois merci dernier la
Commission a déploré une certaine
inertie dans l'application de la loi
dite anct qui date pourtant de 2019 deux
mesures restent en effet à prendre la
première concerne la conclusion d'une
convention définissant les moyens et
ressources dont disposera la NCT pour
reprendre l'émission de l'Agence du
numérique
en février dernier le gouvernement nous
indiquait que cette convention était
toujours en cours de rédaction que
pouvez-vous nous dire sur l'état
d'avancement de cette convention et la
deuxième mesure concerne la transmission
par voie officielle des conventions
concluent entre l'anct et ses opérateurs
partenaires en novembre dernier en
réponse à une question de du rapporteur
Jeunet vous indiquez que vous alliez
faire en sorte que ces conventions
soient transmises au Parlement dans les
formes requises 6 mois plus tard la
transmission pourtant prévue par la loi
est nécessaire au pays narcisses par le
Sénat de sa mission de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement n'est toujours
pas effective donc comment expliquer
vous ces difficultés de transmission
avant de laisser la parole à mes
collègues et en particulier à Louis-Jean
de l'accueil qui siège au conseil
d'administration de la NCT je vous cède
la parole Monsieur le Directeur afin de
répondre à ces quelques points et je
pense qu'ensuite ça tombe de collègues
souhaiteront vous interroger merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs bien effectivement après
quelques mois de prise de fonction et
puis quelques mois devant votre votre
commission je vous m'avez proposé de
demander de revenir voir
je pense qu'en fait il y a plusieurs
aspects je vais peut-être prendre du
coup l'ordre des points que vous évoquez
tout d'abord évoquer la nouvelle
gouvernance de l'agence qui date du mois
de décembre puisque effectivement
j'étais nommé effectivement en début
décembre et le conseil d'administration
renouvelé et lui à nouveau président
mi-décembre donc les ministres eux-mêmes
nous ont donné un certain nombre
d'orientation à compter de fin décembre
début janvier donc nous travaillons dans
ce cadre là peut-être pour reprendre vos
trois points le bilan les perspectives
et puis les sujets de contre
l'application des lois sur lesquelles je
serais peut-être plus rapide puisque
évidemment que il faut que vous ayez la
destination de ces conventions je
pensais que ça avait été fait je vais
m'en assurer dans la meilleure délai
elles sont pas parfaitement publiques
puisque elles ont été présentées à tous
les conseils d'administration donc il y
a vraiment ces cas de difficultés
matérielles
sur le sujet du bilan je m'étais déjà
j'avais déjà évoqué le point lors de
l'audition je ne peux pas rejoindre
complètement la l'appréciation que vous
en avez faite même si effectivement
comment toute chose des progrès doivent
être toujours engagés pour le
développement et la bonne le bon
fonctionnement de l'agence
l'agence est-elle méconnue
sans doute elle n'était-elle pas connue
de tous après trois années de
d'existence ce qui est dans le temps de
nos institutions et de nos systèmes
extrêmement courts d'autant que ces
trois années ont été marquées par au
moins 18 mois de confinement successifs
liés au covid donc pour créer une
structure
issue de la fusion de trois
établissements de trois structures
administratives c'est pas le meilleur
moyen pour se faire connaître lorsqu'on
peut pas aller à la rencontre des gens
vous en conviendrez depuis lors et
maintenant que tous ces questions de
réunion sont levées et notamment depuis
le début de l'année le président et
moi-même avons engagé ce qu'on appelait
un tour de France alors nous n'y allons
pas en vélo peut-être qu'il faudrait
auprès de nombreux départements que nous
avons visité une vingtaine à ce jour et
nous engageons et nous poursuivons ce
travail d'aller à la rencontre des
territoires avec systématiquement une
comptes avec les élus locaux concernés
ou pas par nos programmes par le long
terme aussi dans certains nombre de cas
les services de l'État et avec des
rencontres concrètes avec écouter
comment les choses se passent comment le
déploiement des programmes se met en
oeuvre et les difficultés éventuellement
rencontrées le constat que j'en tire qui
est fondé non pas sur une avis personnel
mais sur l'écoute des personnes que je
rencontre c'est que 1 l'agence est bien
mieux connu que visiblement les choses
sont dites à Paris tous les
interlocuteurs que j'ai rencontré
jusqu'à présent et on a fait beaucoup de
départements avec bien en tête que
l'agence était responsable d'un certain
nombre de programmes qu'il n'est pas
tous le détail de l'ensemble des
missions d'agences je le concède il n'y
a pas de difficulté je tout à fait étant
donné le côté assez important le nombre
de missions que l'AG s'exerce
aujourd'hui néanmoins c'est son
engagement autour de francs services
d'émissions type ACV PVD des territoires
industries et les questions
d'accompagnement d'ingénierie sont bien
identifiés notamment par les élus locaux
et par ailleurs je le constate le bilan
sont là pour le démontrer solliciter
rien que sur l'accompagnement sur mesure
on en est déjà à 1200 accompagnement mis
en oeuvre depuis 2020 21 et c'est
quelque chose qui fonctionne très bien
en complément des dispositifs de chef de
projet que nous avons mis en oeuvre
notamment dans le cas du programme PVD
sur la mobilisation des services de
l'État
elle est effectivement peut-être encore
à perfectionner même si j'ai pu
constater ensemble de départements alors
que les moyens sont quand même limités
un engagement très spécifique avec des
notamment des équipes dédiées au
programme de la NCT qui ont été mis en
oeuvre mais il est vrai toutes les
organisations sont pas similaires ce qui
la richesse de la déconcentration aussi
et dans certains nombre de cas notre
venue a pu contribuer à remobiliser à
actionner et encourager effectivement
les services de l'État pour travailler
toujours mieux sur ces questions et sur
cette dimension d'accompagnement des
collectivités
sur la question de la création d'une
nouvelle strate
l'agence a surtout pas cette vocation
une des difficultés que le rapport du
Sénat diffusait pointé c'est les risques
qui sont contradictoires mais néanmoins
possibles dans les deux cas un d'une
concurrence avec de l'ingénierie locale
des existantes agence la clinique des
départementales c'est UE agent
d'urbanisme intercommunalité aussi qui
peuvent être présentes et à l'inverse le
risque de être insuffisamment présent là
où ces structures sont sont pas ne sont
pas au rendez-vous il faut trouver le
juste le juste milieu et c'est vrai
qu'au bout de trois années on se rend
compte qu'on a besoin de différencier
considérablement nos modalités
d'intervention
en étant finalement présent dans une
animation avec le préfet qui est délégué
territorial et des DT sur les
territoires qui sont bien équipés qui
ont une agence technique qui est déjà
bien présente active un CAE des
intercommunalités armés donc qui
permettent de porter la plupart des
projets donc on intervient en solidarité
sur en revanche on voit qu'un certain
nombre de départements que j'ai pu
rencontrer dans certains cas ont
vraiment besoin d'un accompagnement
beaucoup plus lourd d'une animation plus
forte parce que soit il n'y a pas par
exemple d'agents techniques de partage
vous savez le rapport la pointée que à
peu près un tiers des départements
n'avait pas par ailleurs sur les deux
autres tiers vous avez des organisations
très distinctes établissements publics
régies tous ne font pas tout et c'est
bien normal c'est des choix locaux et
ils ont un rôle néanmoins elles ont un
rôle essentiel notamment sur des
compétences comme la voirie portée par
les petites communes donc c'est
fondamental donc on arrive dans un
nombre de départements à accompagner là
où il n'y a pas effectivement le levier
et l'accompagnement se fait donc de deux
façons les chefs de projet dans un CV
PVD territoire industrie mais aussi
l'accompagnant sur mesure avec le
financement d'opérations plus ponctuelle
exigeant une expertise traitement d'une
friche requalification du centre-ville
dynamisation d'activité commerciale
mise en place d'un pôle culture l toutes
ces objets qui exigent aussi de mettre
en perspective et d'avoir un plan
d'action cohérent donc notre objectif
clairement n'est pas de créer une
nouvelle strate et effectivement il faut
tout prix éviter ceci
sur les financements acvpvd je faudrait
qu'on effectivement je suis à
disposition pour en discuter les bilans
sont fait extrêmement régulièrement
sur le la première vague d'action cœur
de ville l'ensemble des financements
prévus ont été mis en œuvre plus de 5
milliards je rappelle que dès le début
les choses ont été dites on a un
partenariat qui sur action cœur de ville
regroupe Action Logement Lana la banque
des territoires et l'État avec donc des
codes-part prévus pour chacun des
acteurs et il est bien normal que
lorsqu'on attaque notamment la
reconstruction la requalification d'un
centre-ville les sujets soient aussi de
travailler notamment sur l'habitat et le
logement parce qu'en fait un des points
d'entrée c'est comment on arrive aussi à
transformer c'est coeurs de ville pour
rendre et recréer une offre commerciale
attractive et des logements pour lutter
contre la vacance donc ça c'est des
points sur lesquels on a besoin
d'acteurs plutôt du logement parce qu'on
est obligé de passer par des maîtres
d'ouvrage qui ne sont pas les mettre
d'ouvrage classique pour faire des
équipements des aménagements urbains
donc dans le CK en tous les cas le dans
tous les cas les financements prévus par
les grands acteurs de ce programme et
aussi l'état à travers la DETR ont été
présents sur petit lit de demain 3
milliards prévus avec Lana banque des
territoires et nous et aujourd'hui on
est au-delà des 8 900 millions d'euros
engagés au bout de deux ans et demi
sur les perspectives de l'agence je peux
être dire qu'effectivement nous avons
été mandatés pour travailler à une
nouvelle feuille de route monsieur le
Président et qui sera présenté au
concept administration le 29 juin
prochain alors cette feuille de route
vous avez raison on n'est pas dans
rupture parce qu'il y a des programmes
lancés il y a un certain nombre de
dynamiques sur le terrain qu'il doit
être accompagné dans le temps et il
s'agit pas de remettre en cause au
contraire ce qui existe néanmoins et
bien normal et en écoutant aussi les
remarques que le Sénat ou d'autres
acteurs peuvent faire qu'on a juste
qu'on fasse évoluer et qu'on tire des
conséquences et qu'on améliore il s'agit
pas simplement de recommencer à faire la
même chose on est dans un temps très
particulier aussi avec la fin de
première période trigonale action cœur
de ville ou territoire industrie la
première époque s'achève et donc on
repart pour des nouvelles périodes et on
a notamment lancé action cœur de ville 2
et sur territoire d'industrie vous avez
dû lire il y a deux jours les annonces
sur la relance du programme avec
notamment un accompagnement un ingénieur
systématisé et une enveloppe de 100
millions d'euros dédiés annuellement
pour accompagner la réindustrialisation
dans les territoires manuscrits donc
voilà on est dans une étape spécifique
qui est le passage on va dire du du
Prome de de la première vague on va dire
du programme à la deuxième donc c'est
une c'est effectivement un moment un
moment clé pour l'agence
notre orientation c'est tout d'abord de
travailler sur le renforcement de
l'accompagnement sur mesure c'est en
fait toute une méthode d'intervention
que l'on veut sur la base de tout ce qui
nous est remonté éventuel effectivement
du Sénat aussi du terrain c'est d'être
toujours plus proche du terrain à
travers plusieurs orientations qu'on est
en train déjà de mettre en œuvre mais
qu'on poursuivra si la feuille de route
est validée par le conseil
d'administration des recrutements sur
des chars de mission territoriaux plus
nombreux qui vont pouvoir aider aussi
les préfets les DDT et les élus dans
leur projet notamment dans les régions
qui ont le plus de besoin les régions et
les départements puisque dans une région
hyper situation variée les recrutements
sont en cours et on espère dès le
courant 2023 à voir ses moyens
complémentaires une déconcentration de
nos marchés d'ingénierie
d'accompagnement dès 2024 on n'engagera
dès le prochain conseil d'administration
les mesures ce sera aussi un décret
derrière qui permettront au préfet
d'engager les crédits pour que là aussi
tout comme le préfet mais en œuvre les
dotations d'investissement ils puissent
mettre en oeuvre les accompagnements en
ingénierie de façon symétrique
c'est aussi travailler sur la question
du guichet unique c'est un sujet très
compliqué avec chacun en une vision qui
peut être un peu différente notre
approche est de dire il faut être
opérationnel et pragmatique on est
plutôt logique de portail d'accès unique
il faut simplifier les conditions
d'accès à l'accompagnement pour les
territoires et les élus qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas trouvé ce chemin et donc
passer et certains départements mis en
place des outils qui fonctionnent bien
par une adresse mail d'un référent
unique un point d'entrée unique qui fait
pas tout pour tout le monde c'est pas
vrai notre système ne le permettra pas
en revanche qui oriente qui répond et
qui conseille et ça c'est toute notre
action de pouvoir prendre en charge
ensuite ces demandes et les accompagner
le cas échangent des chefs de projet cas
échéant ingénierie sur mesure ou un
autre opérateur ou une intervention d'un
opérateur déjà présente dans le
département le CAE l'agence d'urbanisme
qui peuvent aussi être mobilisés en
fonction de la demande
sur l'accompagnement sur mesure
globalement on doit aussi
chercher à mobiliser plus les autres
acteurs
opérateurs d'État
cerema Adem sont des acteurs clés
notamment dans une période où les
questions de transition prennent une
place encore plus présente encore plus
forte sur les territoires je note par
ailleurs que tous les programmes que je
constate dans leur mise en œuvre
aujourd'hui dans les départements
sont portés par des élus qui mettent en
oeuvre concrètement déjà
toutes les programmes d'action pour
accompagner la transition les
transitions écologiques notamment mais
aussi démographiques donc les élus se
sont totalement emparés de ces sujets là
et ont mis en œuvre à travers des
réflexions sur la sobriété foncière sur
la création notamment de logements
adapté pour faire face à la dépendance
au vieillissement de la population à la
réflexion sur les mobilités aussi pour
permettre aux personnes en situation
dépendante ou plus âgées d'accéder aux
services toute cette réflexion elle est
déjà en cours sur les territoires et
donc elle n'a qu'à elle a besoin surtout
d'être encouragée et d'être démultiplié
mais en tout cas je le constate que les
programmes de l'agence et ce qu'elle a
porté avec les acteurs locaux ont permis
déjà d'avancer sur ces questions
donc notre partenariat avec les grands
acteurs doit reposer sur l'idée qui doit
avoir une offre de service simplifié
entre de nous tous c'est à dire nous
travaillons à des conventions celles que
malheureusement vous n'avez pas encore
reçu j'en suis navré et qu'on ne
manquera pas de vous communiquer des
conventions renouvelées pour les
prochaines années qui doivent garantir
une organisation simplifiée de qui fait
quoi en termes d'ingénierie en gros
répartir les champs d'action pour éviter
le risque de dire qu'il y a trois
acteurs qui peuvent intervenir sur le
même sujet côté tu as bien sûr après que
la gestion de lequel on mobilise ce soit
fait par le chef de projet avec les
services de l'État et nous ça c'est nous
qui gérons la complexité mais en tous
les cas il doit y avoir une capacité y
compris pour les acteurs locaux de
l'état de savoir vers qui se retourner
de façon simple
sur le contenu ensuite de nos programmes
comme je vous le disais et c'est le
deuxième axe de la feuille de route sur
laquelle on travaille après avoir écouté
beaucoup sur le terrain et on continue à
consulter c'est travailler effectivement
sur le renforcement de la dimension des
transitions je l'évoquais beaucoup de
choses ont été faites à travers les
premiers programmes les premiers
accompagnements qu'on a fait depuis 2
ans mais il faut aller bien ils vont
plus loin et démultiplier les efforts la
réflexion sur le territoire industrie
c'est aussi comment on développe une
industrie qui est décarbonée sur les
territoires c'est pas juste on
réindustrialise c'est cette dimension là
qui est à prendre en compte évidemment
c'est aussi tout ce qui concerne
l'observation des territoires sur
lesquels nous allons effectivement
remettre un accent pour apporter des
outils des leviers pour permettre à
chaque territoire mais de disposer de
ces diagnostics territoires aussi le
souhaitent mais au-delà de ça d'offrir
une toute un travail d'analyse
territoriale régulier à travers nos
observatoires qui sont à disposition des
élus et qui doivent être encore mieux
mis en valeur
enfin sur la lisibilité que vous évoquez
monsieur le Président on voit trois
points importants tout d'abord une
mobilisation forte de notre conseil
d'administration qui a la chance d'être
composé de 14 représentants d'élus
nationaux et et locaux dire
représentants d'association des lus
quatre parlementaires dont nous avons
aussi monsieur le sénateur ici présent
qui qui est membre du conseil pour que
ce soit une vraie sens de dialogue et de
co-construction de nos politiques
publiques
de la même façon et j'entends votre
souhait que nous animions encore plus le
réseau territorial c'est bien l'objectif
et nous souhaitons et avec évidemment
les ministres en charge aussi passer un
centre d'instruction au service de
l'Etat pour les encourager à organiser
de façon plus volontariste
l'accompagnement des collectivités
notamment les plus petites le programme
France ruralité typiquement va
s'inscrire dans cette logique là d'un
État qui
sur le secteur les segments c'est à dire
les communes qui ont le plus de
difficulté d'accès à l'ingénierie et à
l'accompagnement leurs projets donner un
et renforcer encore l'effort dans les
années à venir et enfin une
communication qui soit adaptée pour
qu'elle soit moins silotées parce qu'on
nous connaît souvent par programme et un
peu moins sur d'autres qui sait par
exemple que nous portons le l'ensemble
des programmes numériques de déploiement
de la fibre et du mobile sur le
territoire avec 26000 communes déjà
accordés avec les objectifs qui ont été
fixés sur le plan très haut débit qui
sont tenus pas tout le monde donc c'est
plus discret et néanmoins dans un
partenariat avec les collectivités
localement les choses avancent même si
évidemment il peut y avoir des
départements qui sont plus en avance que
d'autres donc cette communication
modifiée elle effectivement c'est un
point important pour nous et notamment
dans une semaine toi tout à fait dans 6
jours précisément le 23 août nous
organisons une journée à quel évidemment
vous êtes tous les sénateurs et un
certain nombre déjà répondu présent pour
venir pour présenter l'ensemble de
l'action de l'agence l'ensemble de
l'offre de services et être aussi en
capacité à travers un centre de stand de
répondre à des demandes qui seraient
adressées par des élus voilà monsieur le
Président peut-être en premier point ce
que je vous indique
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général j'ai
passé la parole à Luc Jean de Nicolaï
mais j'ai oublié de saluer la présence
parmi nous du président de la délégation
à la prospective Mathieu d'Arnaud qui
prendra la parole tout à l'heure
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur Général
que vous avez répondu déjà un certain
nombre de questions mais si vous le
permettez je voudrais surtout
continuez sur un certain domaine
sur sur
la sur l'agence de NCT force est de
constater que la promesse qui nous avait
été faite en 2019 19 d'une agence de
concertation territoriale j'insiste sur
la concertation territoriale doit être
encore développée
dès que certes les comités locaux de
cohésion territoriale ont été créés dans
les départements mais il ne se
réunissent que trop rarement et surtout
il se réduisent malheureusement à l'être
que de simples chambres d'enregistrement
des réalisations faites par l'État à
l'origine normalement c'est comités
locaux devaient être des lieux de
horizontalité ou la collectivité qui
vient avec son projet de territoire
repart avec les conseils avisez des
services de l'État et les perspectives
de financement pérenne et non des
institutions verticales comme très
souvent on observe aujourd'hui Monsieur
le Directeur Général partez chez vous le
constat que je dresse d'une trop grande
verticalité dans les Celtes CLC et
surtout comment la NCT prévoit-t-elle
durant les trois prochaines années de
répondre aux sentiments de manque de
concertation à l'échange locale partager
par beaucoup de collectivités
deuxièmement ce constat à l'échelle
locale et malheureusement partagée à
l'échelle nationale lors de l'examen de
l'approvision de loi portant création de
NCT en 2019 nous avions insisté au sein
de la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable sur
la nécessité d'associer les
collectivités territoriales et le
Parlement à la gouvernance de
l'organisation en tant que membre du
conseil d'administration de la NCT je
regrette que cette collaboration
territoriale ne soit pas mise en place
certes toutes les associations de
collectivités territoriales ainsi que le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale sont
représentés mais nous sommes pour ainsi
dire mise en minorité par les services
de l'État actuellement le conseil
d'administration est ainsi composé de
seulement 10 représentants de
collectivités parlementaires contre 16
représentants de l'État et j'ajoute que
les parlementaires membres du Conseil ne
peuvent pas être représentés par des
suppléants lorsqu'ils ne peuvent pas
venir ce qui est ce qui diminue encore
leur présence troisièmement enfin je
m'interroge sur la capacité la NTT
incarner l'état planificateur qui prend
en compte le temps long et adopte une
vision globale de l'aménagement comme a
pu le faire auparavant la data j'ai
souhaité inviter à cette réunion mon
collègue Mathieu Darnaud président de la
délégation à la prospective pour
insister sur la dimension
intrinsèquement prospective d'une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
cependant force est de constater qu'il
est difficile pour les collectivités
territoriales d'intégrer le temps long
dans leur projet de territoires quand
les différents programmes de financement
sont annualisés excessivement segmentés
Monsieur le Directeur Général comment la
NCT tente-t-elle de répondre à cette
incohérence temporelle entre nécessité
du temps long et assez éviter des
financements alors que l'agence a été
créée pour donner une vision globale
territorialisée et remplit-elle selon
vous sa fonction de planificateur et de
coordinateur
voilà les quelques questions que je
voulais en complément de ce que des
villes président et des réponses que
vous avez déjeuné au parodie à donner
auparavant
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors sur
sur les CLC tout d'abord dire
qu'effectivement d'abord ils ont été mis
en place et
les premières expériences sont pas tout
était totalement à la hauteur peut-être
de ce qui était attendu avec des
logiques parfois un peu descendantes du
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire des
présentations de dispositif alors là
aussi lorsque on est sur des lancements
de programme il n'est pas inutile de de
aussi de présenter les dispositifs je
insiste un CLC au moment où le fond vert
était lancé je pense que les élus
participants étaient plutôt contents
qu'on leur explique ce que c'était le
fond vert et commence à marcher donc je
veux dire c'est il faut pas non plus par
principe rejeter l'idée qui est une
information à travers ces espaces qui
réunissent il faut le savoir donc
beaucoup de représentants des élus mais
aussi des dispositifs d'ingénierie
locaux agents techniques le département
évidemment qui est présent et d'autres
acteurs donc on a comme priorité
effectivement de faire que les CLC soit
beaucoup plus des lieux de débats
d'échanges et de et sans être des lieux
de
de dossiers au cas d'espèces parce que
c'est pas forcément complètement adapté
mais en tout cas d'une meilleure
connaissance de ce fameux inventaire de
l'ingénierie locale il faut savoir que
plusieurs départements l'ont réalisé et
l'ont mis en oeuvre on souhaite
rendre effectivement cette inventaire de
l'ingénierie locale menait dans tous les
départements de façon à ce que y est
cette visibilité disponible pour les
membres du clcd déjà c'est savoir qui
fait quoi parmi les acteurs locaux
publics c'est je pense déjà une première
avancée et puis au sein du clcd qui est
un vrai une vraie animation moins
descendante par rapport aussi aux
problèmes qui se posent très
concrètement moi les déplacements que
j'ai pu mener aujourd'hui je il y a un
problème qui est profondément récurrent
c'est les problématiques notamment sur
tout ce qui concerne les les centres
villes les centres bourgs les petites
centrales mais aussi le monde beaucoup
plus rural c'est la question des
logements vacants avec le traitement de
et juridique et financier et en maîtrise
d'ouvrage c'est un sujet complexe avec
des communes qui ont réussi à trouver
des solutions astucieuses donc c'est
comment partage ça aussi les solutions
les outils les leviers à travers ces
instances départementales parce qu'il y
a des départements il y en a d'ailleurs
aussi à l'actif une intercoactive il y a
une scène il y a une SPL puis il y a des
départements il y a pas donc comment on
fait voilà est-ce qu'il faut une
maîtrise ouvrage communale comme on
l'accompagne comme on la soutient donc
tout ça c'est des débats qui peut être
que locaux qu'on pourra pas traiter au
niveau national
sur le travail au sein du conseil
d'administration bon comme je vous le
disais c'est une priorité notamment du
président d'avoir une animation
différente et vous avez dû voir que déjà
dans les précédents conseils
d'administrations substantiellement
modifié les ordres du jour pour mettre
les points de discussion au début en
présentant aussi les actions et les
différents programmes et les actualités
et en ayant des échanges sur les
questions j'évoquais le numérique tout à
l'heure et notamment ce qui a eu des
échanges sur les difficultés sur la
maintenance sur les raccordements des
vraies questions concrètes auxquelles
une partie des équipes a pu répondre
donc c'est intéressant d'avoir ce type
d'échange mais voilà après il y a une
gouvernance qui est prévue par la loi et
décret sur la composition moi j'ai pas
le sentiment qui est la moindre fracture
entre l'ensemble des membres du conseil
d'administration qui soit état
collectivité on est plutôt dans une
démarche de construction collective que
de recherche d'une majorité les uns sur
les sentiments
sur l'étape planificateur et la data moi
je suis beaucoup je suis un peu mal à
l'aise sur cette affaire à vrai dire je
vais être assez assez franc si il avait
voulu si on avait voulu créer la data
fallait garder la data enfin je pense
qu'il faut aussi qu'on soit cohérent le
souhait du Parlement et du gouvernement
était de créer une agence dont on nous
demande quels sont en proximité or un
moment il a schizophrénie elle s'est
limite donc moi je dois aussi concentrer
les efforts sur ce qui nous semble le
plus prioritaire et l'accompagnement des
territoires c'est ce que vous nous
demandez de faire c'est ce que je
ressens comme un besoin est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on doit
concentrer nos efforts sur une
planification stratégique à 30 ans alors
même qu'aujourd'hui on a des acteurs au
moins deux que je vais vous citer
nouveau qui ont ce sont positionnés sur
ces sujets là dans la sphère
institutionnelle je pense à France
stratégie qui a du fait du travail de
réflexion sur du long terme je pense
aussi à au commissariat aux plans qui a
été réinstualisé je suis plus mesuré
pour autant pour autant je vous en ai
parlé tout à l'heure nous avons des
outils d'analyse territoriale de
diagnostic territorial donc moi je
positionne pas dans l'idée d'être un
grand planificateur une agence n'a pas
vocation à donner des instructions aux
autres ministères sur comment ils
doivent se développer ou s'organiser ce
n'est pas notre rôle nous sommes dans
des tutelles ministériels dans ce sens
là que ça se passe en revanche nous
avons des outils pour permettre de mieux
comprendre les territoires leur
dynamique et ça ces études nous les
menons et évidemment elles doivent
servir à la décision collective je pense
à l'étude sur la ruralité qui sera
présentée mardi prochain à nouveau qui
extrêmement riche que nous avons porté
et qui permet de connaître les
dynamiques des ruralités puisque la
ruralité ça n'existe pas il y a des
ruralités des ruralités en grande
difficulté des réalités qui vont
extrêmement bien des réalités
touristiques des réalités agricoles
industrielles périurbaine riche pauvres
enfin c'est une c'est une grande variété
de situation y compris dans un
département et la qualification déjà du
sujet et la première étape pour pouvoir
les acteurs publics les acteurs locaux
pour y apporter apporter des réponses et
des solutions parce qu'on n'est pas
confronté au même sujet quand on est une
petite commune qui subit une pression
foncière en termes d'installation
population quand on est dans un
territoire avec une perte de d'activité
d'emploi et avec un sujet de perte de
population donc concrètement oui
là-dessus il faut qu'on soit toujours
présent avec des analyses territoriales
opérationnels à destination Network pour
éclairer l'addition publique mais est-ce
que c'est notre champ aujourd'hui d'être
un état planificateur l'agence que je
suis je m'interroge je crois pas que ce
soit complètement ça qui est présidé à
la création de l'agence
oui merci Monsieur le Directeur juste un
mot mais je vais vous prendre un exemple
sur planification par exemple j'ai
demandé dans mon département qu'on
modélise une zone par exemple sur un
territoire j'ai demandé trois fois le
DDT des réponses
différemment etc alors où on fait la
concertation avec les élus et avec des
propositions ou après ou et on accepte
et on travaille en planifie ou alors
c'est l'état de façon verticale qui
décide et dans ces cas-là autant qu'on
n'est pas d'idée ça peut nous arriver
pas avoir d'idées mais je vous dis c'est
toi quand on est voilà quand on demande
quelque chose une planification sur des
politiques qui sont extrêmement
importantes et sur laquelle les élus
sont inquiets un petit peu je crois que
pour les rassurer ou pour les inquiéter
c'est utile d'avoir sur des territoires
des propositions de de modélisation de
de ce que peut-être à 10 ans 15 ans 20
ans une les conséquences d'une
zone
je vous rejoins là je pense qu'on est
clément là on est on est on est
complètement en lien c'est à dire que
c'est les disposer des outils
d'accompagnement en termes de capacité
de prospective là je pense qu'on rejoint
plus nos missions on essaie de
développer un salon d'outils répondants
aux besoins il faut qu'on se rapproche
aussi des services concernés il y a des
réflexions sur ces des outils de
modélisation qui commence on est associé
mais on n'est pas forcément porteur seul
voilà
merci la parole au président d'Arnaud
avant de série de trois questions
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
directeur chez Louis-Jean
juste un mot pour revenir sur ce que
vous avez dit Monsieur le Directeur
lorsque je me souviens du débat que nous
avons eu ici même en séance il y a
quelques années s'agissant de la
création de la NCT et pour rebondir sur
ce que vous disez à l'instant le choix
d'une agence c'était pour répondre à un
besoin d'agilité sur les territoires
d'une structure qui viendrait comme je
le disais de façon très agile s'intégrer
dans un écosystème en matière
d'ingénierie notamment existant
malheureusement on a quand même un peu
le sentiment et le premier point sur la
lisibilité m'amène à vous dire
aujourd'hui ce que je vous ai déjà
évoqué lors de l'audition sur la mission
sur l'avenir de la commune c'est que on
a le sentiment quand même dans beaucoup
de territoire de la veut même de l'État
territorial des préfets sous préfet que
nous avons auditionné qu'il y a comme
une forme de doublon puisque
que l'ingénierie départementale
continuait à exister la NCT vient
notamment dans la cadre de la politique
d'appel à projet sur petite ville de
demain action cœur de ville et d'autres
politiques d'appel à projet s'intégrer
dans ce dispositif d'ingénierie et je
dis au passage en oubliant parfois
des pentes territoire qui ne rentrent
pas dans cette labellisation et puis
le directeur le démat nous a indiqué
hier que l'État entendait recruter
encore une centaine de spécialistes sur
sur l'ingénierie des agents qui seraient
qui seraient mutualisés donc il y a
quand même une question de lisibilité
qui m'amène à parler du second point
c'est-à-dire l'efficience l'intérêt
d'une agence et celui qui parle n'est
pas un fervent partisan de la
gencification de l'État parce que pour
moi il y a quand même à terme un risque
de perte en ligne c'est quand même le
service rendu aux élus et à défaut
puisque vous n'êtes pas un adepte de
l'appellation guichet il y a quand même
un intérêt à mettre en cohérence les
politiques de l'État notamment
l'ingénierie on va dire que pour le coup
la NCT accompagné
l'ingénierie par le financement de
chargé de mission d'agent auprès
notamment des collectivités qui sont
labellisées petite ville de demain
action cœur de ville mais il reste
l'autre pendant c'est à dire la capacité
à derrière enclencher du financement et
là je trouve que on a encore un effort à
faire puisque on a vu cette année la
complexité
pour pour les collectivités de rentrer
dans des dispositifs comme le fond vert
s'ajoutent à cela la DETR au niveau
départemental la décile au niveau
régional et l'incapacité chronique
parfois que l'on a à mettre tout ça en
relation étant entendu que ce qui
aujourd'hui légitime cette
différenciation entre les dotations
c'est justement qu'elle relève
finalement d'ambition ou de finalité
différente or
et là je prends un témoin l'ensemble des
collègues il n'est pas un département où
le préfet n'actionne pas les différents
dispositifs quand on rentre pas dans la
des terres on va chercher dans la
desciles et quand on rentre pas dans la
descente aujourd'hui on va on va
chercher dans le fond vert est-ce que je
vous disais la dernière fois c'est
pourquoi on ne met pas tout ça en
cohérence pour rendre des choses plus
accessibles plus efficientes plus
rapides et à contrario et j'en finirai
par là
ce qui est un petit peu gênant pour les
législateurs que nous sommes c'est que
nous avons essayé notamment dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finances
d'identifier des priorités et ça me
ramène à ce que disait Louis Jean de
Nicolay sur la nécessité de
planification parce qu'il faut quand
même voir un peu à long terme les
besoins de nos territoires je prends un
exemple le plan le programme sur les
ponts nous avions voté 90 millions
d'euros aujourd'hui personne je dis bien
personne au premier rang desquels les
préfets n'est capable de dire où sont
passés exactement ces 90 millions et
comment faut-il faire pour les actionner
étant convaincu que toutes et tous ici
sur nos territoires nous avons besoin de
moyens sur des sujets qui sont
budgétivores pour pour nos collectivités
pour nos communes et donc au final
on attend de la NCT clairement
quelle réponde à cette double exigence
de lisibilité lisibilité conditionnant
l'accès à la NCT et défic ience pour
activer à la fois l'ingénierie mais
surtout derrière les financements des de
l'État quel qu'il soit je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général
oui je pense que
d'accord sur les objectifs on le partage
sur la lisibilité je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure c'est un élément clé de notre
feuille de route c'est aussi rendre plus
simple accessible alors je disais
guichet unique c'est parce que je
guichet tout le monde y compris au
niveau local peut mal interpréter en
disant le guichet on se présente on a on
a un financement en fait c'est plutôt
l'idée d'un point d'entrée d'un point
d'orientation et d'une organisation qui
fonctionne et qui soit la plus simple
possible pour les élus qui ont un projet
ou une réflexion pour les accompagner
donc je pense que c'est vraiment
l'objectif doublons etc vraiment
vraiment nous on a on a écrit on met en
oeuvre on est dans le livre de
subsidiarité alors parfois c'est pas
compris parce que c'est vrai que quand
on a une demande une commune qui répond
parfaitement à ce que les gens
techniques départementales peut faire on
renvoie vers l'annonce technique
départementale c'est pas toujours bien
vécu bon voilà c'est une réalité aussi
concrète ça donc il faut qu'on soit
aussi tous garant du respect de
l'intervention de chacun
pour autant il faut savoir aussi qu'on a
des endroits où il n'y a pas de réponse
complète exhaustive et notamment vous
évitez vous évoquez chez le sénateur
Nicolaï aussi sur l'idée quand même
alors plutôt planification c'est de un
peu une prospective territoriale une
capacité à programmer son un projet un
projet territorial et ça c'est vraiment
important de pouvoir c'est souvent ce
qui manque en fait en termes de
d'accompagnement local c'est de disposer
une capacité pour le territoire
intercommunalité ou commune d'avoir une
projection de se dire à 5 ans quels sont
quel plan d'action je dois déployer pour
faire face aux enjeux que je rencontre
déjà quels sont les enjeux que je
rencontre parfois déjà commencer par ça
et comment je mets quels moyens et quel
plan d'action
soutenable en termes d'ingénierie sous
table en termes financier pour la
communion intercommunalité ça c'est tout
un travail qu'on a pu commencer à mettre
en oeuvre avec les accompagnements qu'on
a mis sur les CRPE mais qui doivent être
continué poursuivi et on voit bien que
là on est publicité ça apporte
énormément c'est très bien reçu par les
élus parce que ça leur donne une mise en
perspective donc ça c'est l'aspect
lisibilité travailler mieux avec les
acteurs locaux et apporter une offre de
service qui répond aux besoins adaptés
du territoire sur l'Efficient
c'est-à-dire la capacité à passer une
fois qu'on a le programme le plan
d'action la réflexion c'est comment le
met en œuvre il commence et vous l'avez
indiqué déjà monsieur le rapporteur hier
avoir des inquiétudes sur et comment on
finance derrière les projets qui vont
émerger notamment dans les programmes
petits lieux demain
d'abord vous l'avez indiqué il y a eu
cette année l'arrivée d'un nouveau fond
de 2 milliards le fond vert sans que les
eaux dotations de l'État baisse donc au
total on a 4 milliards dotations de
l'État à l'instant où je parle moi je
n'ai pas connaissance de communes PVD
qui nous est signalé un problème de
financement sur ces projets il n'y a pas
d'enveloppe préservée il y a une
priorisation qui a prévu par les
circulaires ministériel sur les
programmes il y a des débats sans fin
sur faut-il une enveloppe à une
enveloppe je peux pas y répondre
aujourd'hui et puis c'est un choix aussi
qui appartient au Parlement et au
gouvernement néanmoins aujourd'hui on
n'est pas confronté à une impossibilité
de financement la chance qu'on a eu et
qu'on a dans nos programmes
c'est qu'on a une capacité à s'inscrire
dans le temps je vous rejoins ce
problème de visibilité aussi pour que
l'action locale puisse s'installer les
programmes que l'on porte font 3,5 ans
selon les programmes donc ça permet de
se dire je serai accompagné par un chef
de projet les 904 chefs de projet PVD
que nous cofinancement 904 aujourd'hui
sont inscrits dans la durée jusqu'à 2026
et donc il y a aucune inquiétude
aujourd'hui ils sont recrutés ils
fonctionnent ils travaillent et il
déploie toute une réflexion très utile
donc ils peuvent s'inscrire dans le
temps ce qui permet de poser aussi
l'inquiétude sur la question
effectivement des financements les
enveloppes annoncées je prends pour les
grands programmes mais c'est le cas
aussi à quelques jours sur le territoire
industrie c'est une enveloppe qui sont
certes pas plus réelles au sens
budgétaire du terme puisque le budget il
est annuel mais qui s'inscrivent dans
des engagements plus réels c'est-à-dire
quand on a dit il y a 3 milliards
d'euros qui seront consacrés à petit
lieu demain nous faisons un décompte
précis réguliers annuel ligne par ligne
et on peut vous en rendre compte ligne
par ligne ce qui est du prêt ce qui est
la subvention ce qui est l'ingénierie ce
qui est de la DETR ce qui est la D6 qui
est du fond vert on a tout ça chaque
année on a ce point précis ligne et donc
ces engagements sont suivis et donc ces
3 milliards prévus sur non seulement mis
en œuvre en général je n'ai aucun doute
mais sans doute dépassé après il y a la
question il faut peut-être plus et
cetera il y aura un temps peut-être de
réflexion en tous les cas moi je vous
rejoins sur un point ce besoin de de
prévisibilité de visibilité pour que on
puisse aussi amener les territoires à
s'engager dans ses projets qui sont
parfois assez lourds et qu'il n'y ait
pas cette inquiétude de dire bon
maintenant je vais sortir le projet mais
j'aurais pas les financements derrière
pour pouvoir les mener donc clairement
cette cette la cohérence en fait du
dispositif d'accompagnement territoire
c'est quand même deux pieds c'est de
l'ingénierie pour aider à l'émergence et
à l'accompagnement des projets mais
c'est aussi effectivement une dimension
d'investissement pour avoir l'effet
levier et permettre leur mise en œuvre
merci une première série de trois
interventions Patricia demain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général Messieurs mes chers
collègues
mes questions intéresseront le numérique
d'abord le financement des raccordements
complexes à la fibre la phase de
candidature de l'appel à projet lancé
par le gouvernement et la MCT en 2022
pour aider les collectivités
territoriales à financer les
raccordements complexes à la fibre en
zone rip c'est achevé le 17 avril
dernier je souhaiterais faire un point
d'étape sur ce dispositif Monsieur le
Directeur Général à savoir combien de
collectivités étaient éligibles à
l'appel à projet et parmi elles combien
ont déposé un dossier de candidatures
avez-vous une idée du nombre de
raccordement qui pourront qui pourront
ainsi être subventionnés car comme
chacun le sait les 150 millions d'euros
prévus par le gouvernement seront très
loin de suffire pour financer l'ensemble
des raccordements dit long et complexes
à la fibre qui représente un coup situé
entre 1 et 2 milliards d'euros afin de
sortir de cette impasse financière je
souhaiterais savoir qu'elle regarde vous
portez sur l'idée d'instituer un fond de
péréquation portant sur les réseaux
fibres notamment mis en avant par la
Vica ma deuxième question concerne le
guichet de cohésion numérique des
territoires qui est piloté par l'anct le
guichet cohésion numérique qui permet
des défis financièrement des ménages à
acquérir une technologie alternative à
la fibre a été prolongée en avril 2022
le montant maximal de l'aide a été
rehaussée de 150 à 300 euros et peut
atteindre 600 euros sur conditions de
ressources dans mon rapport
d'information de mars 2022 sur la
cohésion numérique des territoires
j'avais souligné que le guichet unique
que le guichet de cohésion numérique
pardon des territoires créés en 2019
était caractérisée par un taux de
recours très bas de la part des usagers
sans doute imputables à une forte
méconnaissance du dispos
où en est-on du déploiement de ce
dispositif et quelles actions ont été
mises en oeuvre depuis un an pour mieux
le faire connaître des usagers en fin ma
dernière question intéressent l'enjeu de
la pérennisation des conseillers
numériques françaises
s'agissant des 4000 conseillers
numériques françaises cofinancés par
l'État à hauteur de 50 000 euros par
poste la loi de finances pour 2023 a
prolonger les contrats en cours pour une
durée de 1 an sans toutefois tranchées
sur le devenir du dispositif ou de cet
échéance une concertation devait se
tenir avec des collectivités
territoriales et associations d'élus en
2023 sur l'avenir du dispositif et la
participation financière de l'État à sa
mise en oeuvre pardon pouvez-vous faire
un point sur l'avancée de ces
discussions
les élus sont preneurs de toute
information sur le sujet vous le pensez
bien dans le sens où les dynamiques
locales risque d'être perturbé par la
fin de ce dispositif d'ici la fin de
l'année je vous remercie
Bruno Belin
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues quel décalage entre la réalité
de ce qu'on voit sur les territoires
dont nous sommes les élus et un certain
nombre de propos que vous avez pu tenir
là ce matin Monsieur le Directeur
Général d'avoir je fais le lien avec
l'intervention très concrète et très
pratique au pratique de Patricia Damas
sur la fibre vous vous appropriez la NCT
a fait la fibre je peux vous assurer
qu'il y a pas un territoire où la NCT a
été le moteur ou est identifié
heureusement qu'il y a eu j'ai ma gauche
mon collègue Gilbert Favreau avec lequel
nous étions présidente département quand
nous avons créé pour tout numérique
heureusement qu'on a pas attendu une
agence quelconque pour pouvoir le faire
sinon nos territoires on serait resté au
téléphone standard donc vous regrettez
qu'il y a plus de Data des fois on le
regrette sur les territoires ruraux
parce que moi ils avaient des envies des
aménagement et j'ai en tête les routes
nationales Vous vous excusez derrière le
fait que le covid ouais ça échapper à
personne mais au contraire vous auriez
dû être la plus pour soutenir les élus
notamment ceux qui ont été nouvellement
élus parmi les maires en 2020 parce que
quel état de souffrance il constate
après 3 ans de mandat ou pour certains
pas identifié pas connu ne sachant pas
comment lancer leur projet alors que
votre première mission je cite j'ouvre
les guillemets étaient d'une fabrique à
projets donc ce qu'on voit c'est que
finalement on en est très loin vous avez
cité petite ville de demain là encore
moi je rencontre tous les mois des élus
sur le territoire
où j'exerce mon mandat et petite ville
de demain on entend inertie ça avance
pas alors que derrière je suis convaincu
qu'il y ait une volonté et heureusement
qu'on les a d'un corps préfectoral de
sous-préfect qui accompagne les élus
mais la NCT n'est pas du tout dans cette
dynamique j'entends encore dans vos
propos ce matin recrutement alors que
vous dites vous-même on renvoie sur les
agences techniques
donc je crains qu'on est beaucoup
d'inertie c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé mon propos par quel décalage
alors il y a ce rapport
parce que finalement on demande
aujourd'hui aux communes de faire plus
avec moins et puis que effectivement les
communes heureusement qu'on les a pour
avoir des projets d'investissement mais
qu'elle décale parce que quand je lis le
rapport qui a été fait avec beaucoup de
talents par Cécile Brunet et Charles
gainé je cite j'ouvre les guillemets une
approche encore trop descendante et peu
attentive aux dynamiques locales peut
attentive aux dynamiques locales et
d'une promesse de simplification et de
meilleurs soutien au projet locaux non
tenus donc voilà on est loin du pratico
pratique on est loin du à quoi ça sert
et donc
comment allez-vous aider enfin les élus
à monter les projets alors qu'ils sont
maintenant à l'aube de leur deuxième
partie de ma seconde partie de mandat
quelle stratégie comptez-vous mettre en
place pour mener à bien votre mission
première et vraiment j'insiste
heureusement nous avons les agences
techniques et le corps sous préfectoral
pour accompagner les élus parce que
aujourd'hui
c'est eux qui font le boulot là NCT
personne ne les connaît
Stephen Denis
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général la NCT a été créée
effectivement en janvier 2020 afin de
faciliter l'avancée des projets dans le
territoire comme vient de le rappeler
mon collègue Belin 3 ans après il semble
que la NCT souffre d'un manque de
notoriété auprès des élus quand elle
n'est pas perçue comme nebuleuse
bureaucratique ou tout simplement
inutile
52% des élus connaissent mal les
services proposés par l'agence
établissement public rappelons-le de 344
agents et de 60 millions d'euros de
budget
ce constat c'est celui qui a été fait
par la Délégation aux collectivités
territoriales du Sénat
par ailleurs trois quarts des élus
indique n'avoir jamais sollicité la NCT
notamment en raison de la méconnaissance
des offres et services de l'agence au
problème de visibilité ce greffe donc
comme l'a dit Mathieu Darnaud un
problème de lisibilité votre chantier
sur le directeur général et vous arrivez
donc vous n'avez pas de responsabilité
particulière par rapport à ce constat
mais votre chantier est titanesque c'est
un 12 euphémisme de le dire pour pallier
ce problème de notoriété quels sont les
partenariats que vous allez ou que vous
avez initié avec les associations
nationales d'élus locaux
c'est le directeur
merci monsieur le Président tout d'abord
sur les sujets numériques alors je suis
désolé madame sénatrice j'ai pas là
aujourd'hui et je suis pas venu avec les
personnes le nombre précis de
communiquer éligi mais non précis de
dossiers je propose c'est qu'on vous
fera un point qu'on vous transmettra
dans les prochains jours en tous les cas
vous dire que là-dessus effectivement il
y a une attention forte sur ces
questions de raccordement complexes
alors aussi peut-être en répondant à
Monsieur sénateur Belin effectivement et
je l'ai indiqué dans mon propos loin de
moi l'idée de dire que c'était l'agence
qui avait fait d'ailleurs l'agence en
fait
c'est elle c'est les compétences
numériques de l'Alliance numérique
initialement a été chargée du plan
déploiement fibre et mobile à part des
subventions et ça vous en serez d'accord
avec le FSN qu'aujourd'hui on a récupéré
qui était porté par la caisse d'EPO qui
est dispose de plusieurs milliards
d'euros qui vient en soutien des
structures qui portent effectivement les
plans de la fibre départementale
syndicat mix selon les configurations
locales sur les zones et moi soutien à
dire de façon très très simple que le
déploiement sur les zones est plutôt un
succès et qu'on doit à l'action
collective de l'ensemble des
collectivités publiques
et connaît un déploiement rapide et fort
là aussi il y a quelques variations dans
quelques départements mais globalement
un déploiement qui est pas loin des 70%
sur les zones et on atteindra les
objectifs qui ont été fixés pour 2025 on
a on voit apparaître aussi d'ailleurs et
c'est intéressant en terme de
statistiques un déploiement de plus
rapide et de meilleure qualité sur les
zones RIP que sur les zones urbanisées
qui sont portées directement vous le
savez par les opérateurs sur lesquels
les interventions des collectivités
publiques et de voilà et n'est pas du
tout le même nature donc le c'est une
chance pour les territoires et moi je
reviens peut-être à nos missions
fondamentales que ok c'est la fracture
territoriale qui existait à travers
l'accès ou pas au numérique et Internet
et en train de se résorber notamment sur
les territoires les plus ruraux les plus
enclavés et que on a je prétends je
cherche pas à dire que c'est de ma faute
je suis très modeste là dessus et c'est
pas au bout de quatre mois de présence
que j'aurais ce propos là je dis
simplement que il y a quand même des
crédits qui ont été mis et que vous le
savez et que c'est non négligeable non
plus et que cette avancée elle est pour
tout le monde et que c'est une vraie
réussite collective pour les territoires
et il y a quelques années sous ce sujet
de la fracture numérique était une
question extraordinaire puissante et qui
était un frein au développement de toute
activité y compris économique sur ces
territoires ça considérablement changé
et c'est une évolution qui est très
positive dans une dynamique
effectivement territoriale sur les
questions de guichet sur notamment les
solutions alternatives et que le recours
faible je vais refaire un point sur ce
sur ce sujet je pense que il y a mes
connaissances effectivement encore de
ces outils de par la communication
collective autour de la poursuite du
raccordement
sur la fibre et puis l'implantation des
relais sur les mobiles qui restent quand
même on va dire la priorité première on
a on voit bien les premières réflexions
qui nous remontent aussi des territoires
sur notamment sur l'implantation de sur
le mobile de qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
une fois qu'on aura atteint le
déploiement des 5000 relais qui ont été
prévus par le plan qu'est-ce qui se
passe après donc tout le monde est
encore je pense quand même dans l'idée
que dans le déploiement de la fibre dans
le déploiement du mobile de l'antenne
classique 4G et peut-être moins dans des
solutions alternatives qui exigeront
pour atteindre les 100% de couverture
des solutions comme vous l'avez indiqué
des solutions qui jouent avec un peu
plus de de finesse parce qu'il ne sera
pas possible de mettre la fibre à tous
les endroits et ni mettre forcément un
poteau de relais à tous les endroits il
y aura des endroits faudra jouer
effectivement sur des solutions
complémentaires
sur la question des conseillers
numériques je les travaux effectivement
sur le sur le sujet notamment à l'issue
du CNR sur le numérique ont amené le
Ministre en charge barreau à faire un
centre de communication notamment sur un
travail à mener la communication date du
mois d'avril donc c'est encore tout
récent sur un travail mené sur le les
évolution notamment de toute cette
filière qui a connu un développement
extraordinaire puissant au moment du
covid et tout ce qui concerne donc
l'accompagnement et l'inclusion
numérique donc nous sommes assez
effectivement mobilisés pour essayer de
faire avancer ce sujet vous le savez
l'État a débloqué une enveloppe alors
pour moi il était trial mais dégressive
il est vrai d'accompagnement financier
sur les conseiers numériques à l'issue
du plan de relance la question du modèle
et de son financement restant posé
au-delà je vous rejoins on voit à quel
point ce sont des relais importants
notamment par exemple dans les Francs
services mais pas que aussi j'en ai vu
dans des tirs lieux ça fonctionne très
bien et voir comment cette cette métier
en fait puisqu'on est sur une évolution
assez forte ce métier peut trouver sa
place dans les années à venir avec en
fait une professionnalisation de la
filière de la médiation numérique donc
c'est effectivement les concertations
devraient démarrer après les résultats
du CNR numérique
sur monsieur monsieur le sénateur Belin
sur la question des recrutements etc
alors qu'il n'y a pas de malentendu on
notre objectif c'est justement
d'accompagner encore plus les
territoires vous avez dit les
sous-préfets font l'action et non n'est
pas connu mais dans une certaine mesure
moi ça me gêne pas puisque les sous
préfets et les préfets sont de
représentants sur le territoire donc moi
j'ai pas vocation à arriver dans tous
les territoires et décider à la place
des préfets les sous-préfet nous sommes
dans une logique de déconcentration moi
le délégué territorial de l'agence c'est
le préfet c'est le législateur qui a
décidé donc moi qu'on me connaissent pas
ça me gêne pas ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
connaisse et que les politiques
publiques puissent être mis en oeuvre
donc c'est aussi un peu la contradiction
faut-il une faut-il que l'agence soit
nécessairement connue de tout le monde
ou faut-il que les politiques publiques
de l'État d'accompagnement territoire
soit mis en oeuvre j'aurais tendance à
dire que c'est plutôt la deuxième le
deuxième objectif qui me guide donc
concrètement les sous-prés les préfets
disposent des outils et d'un
accompagnement et les recrutements dont
je parlais visa aider et à étoffer
renforcer les moyens des équipes de
l'État pour accompagner les territoires
c'est ça ce qu'on veut faire c'est être
en support parce que c'est pas avec nos
300 personnes qu'on va régler tous les
problèmes de tous les territoires il
faut s'appuyer sur toute la dynamique
locale et comme vous l'avez indiqué très
justement avec les agences techniques
départementales avec lesquels moi j'ai
bon nombre de cas où ça se passe très
bien elles sont totalement impliquées
par exemple dans l'immation des chefs de
projet petit ville de demain pour aussi
leur apporter des soutiens pour la mise
en oeuvre de leurs projets donc là
dessus effectivement on est vraiment
dans l'idée à travers un les chefs de
projet de l'accompagnement sur mesure
mobilisée par les préfets mis en oeuvre
au niveau local de d'aider l'ensemble
des territoires à monter les projets et
ensuite à travers l'ingénierie et
ensuite elle est financée
sur monsieur le sénateur de mini sur le
manque de notoriété bon on se rejoint de
faut-il la notoriété faut-il l'action je
pense que c'est un peu les deux moi j'ai
le sentiment je suis dans les
déplacements que je fais alors peut-être
que je vis dans un monde parallèle je
l'espère pas complètement que il y a
quand même en face de moi des élus qui
savent à peu près de ce qu'on fait mais
que ça touche pas tous les ulules j'en
ai bien conscience et qui il y a un
travail à faire il y a aucun doute il
faut qu'on travaille effectivement dans
un partenaire avec l'association d'élus
évidemment d'abord comme les sénateurs
tout à l'heure son membre du conseil
d'administration au travail toujours
plus on est en échange beaucoup avec
certaines dans le cas de nos programmes
on a aussi et je l'ai engagé il y a
quelques jours encore des échanges plus
informels avec aussi les directeurs
d'associations d'élus il faut qu'on ait
une voilà on est en échange permanent
dans la réalité dans la mise en œuvre
concrète de nos de nos projets lorsqu'on
travaille sur la question de sensualité
et le salut directeur général de la MF
ici présent dans nos tribunes ainsi que
la directrice générale de
l'intercommunalité de France on a des
échanges avec les intercommunalités ou
avec l'association des meilleurs héros
évidemment évidemment donc ça se
co-construit après il y a un arbitrage
effectivement côté état ça peut ne pas
être à 100% ce qui était voulu par les
en et par les autres mais ces échanges
ils ont lieu enfin je le dis au
quotidien qui faille les poursuivent les
renforcer les intensifier évidemment
c'est mon objectif
merci deuxième série de trois questions
Martine filleul
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur général je me suis très
investie sur les questions d'inclusion
numérique pendant ce mandat en
particulier au sein de la commission
supérieure du numérique et des postes et
j'ai réalisé dans ce cadre un bilan
déconseillé numérique donc vous ne serez
pas étonné que je vous interroge sur la
nouvelle feuille de route du ministre
Jean-Noël Barrault qui organise
l'inclusion numérique pour les années
2023 à 2027 et je souhaitais plus
particulièrement donc vous interrogez
sur la question de la désignation d'une
collectivité territoriale pilote pour
structurer cette politique d'inclusion
numérique donc le ministre a bien
précisé que ce n'était pas la même
collectivité territoriale qui devait
être pilote dans chaque territoire et
donc je voulais vous demander comment
vous allez organiser ce travail puisque
a priori vous allez être le pilote de ce
travail pour l'inclusion numérique dans
ces années là pour qu'on ait un maillage
relativement efficace et équilibré et
que chaque territoire puisse travailler
ensemble sur ces questions d'un ensemble
et en même temps sur ces questions
d'inclusion numérique le ministre a
également annoncé à un fond pluriannuel
coordonné par la NCT comment
envisagez-vous donc de le ventiler enfin
on finit en troisième question moi de la
même manière et je reviendrai sur la
question qui vous a déjà été posée
comment envisagez-vous de pérenniser les
postes de conseillers numériques dont
vous venez de dire qu'il joue un rôle
tout à fait important pour les citoyens
qui se sentent abandonnés sur ces
questions et puis enfin quatrième sujet
les hub régionaux dans certaines régions
comme la mienne les assembleurs ce
régional joue parfaitement son rôle mais
il semble que dans d'autres régions ce
ne soit pas exactement le cas comment
est-ce que vous allez fonctionner par
rapport à cette héritage des hubs je
vous remercie merci Nicole Bonnefoy
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général mes chers collègues
les ambitions portées par la NCT à sa
création faisait à peu près consensus si
on l'a dit à savoir comme nous
connaissons le besoin de solutions
d'ingénierie pour les collectivités
territoriales c'était donc une réponse
en premier lieu pour les communes ce
besoin d'ingénierie en l'absence de
réponse de l'État souvent été assumée
cela a été dit pleinement par l'échelon
départemental notamment à travers les
agences techniques départementales mais
également les c.io ingénierie gratuite
de qualité à préserver par sa faible
visibilité dans les territoires la NCT
constitue toujours pas le guichet unique
ou le portail d'accès comme vous l'avez
qualifié tout à l'heure pourtant attendu
par les élus à sa création pire comme le
note le rapport sénatorial publié en
février dernier le recours massif a des
bureaux de consultants privés tant à
offrir des prestations copiées collées
sans ancrage dans le territoire qui ne
conviennent pas au porteur de projet
ainsi comment la NCT compte améliorer sa
coordination indispensable je parle avec
un ingénierie publique local qui réalise
un véritable accompagnement de proximité
parce que elle connaît les élus parce
qu'elle connaît les territoires parce
qu'elle maîtrise les projets bien plus
que les bureaux d'études privées donc
par ailleurs comment la NCT qui défend
l'idée d'un accompagnement sur mesure
contrôle le tel la qualité des
prestations justement des cabinets
privés vers à lesquels elle oriente les
élus ça c'est ma première question
le gouvernement semble vouloir
développer une nouvelle offre
d'ingénierie spécifique à la demande des
communes rurales exclues de fait des
programmes précédents vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure ce nouveau programme se
fondrait sur un concours de financement
entre les collectivités territoriales et
l'État
sur la masse de ces premiers éléments je
souhaite également souligner la
recommandation du Sénat
issue de l'enquête sénatoriale de mieux
incarner l'anxiété en désignant les
sous-préfets pilotes du programme en
lien direct avec les élus locaux ça a
été dit tout à l'heure c'est une bonne
chose ceci dit nombre de sous-préfet je
le vois c'est moi chez moi sont
évidemment prêts à assumer ce rôle là
mais manque sérieusement de moyens
de moyens de personnel on voit bien
comment l'État se délitent sur nos
territoires y compris dans les
préfectures et sous-préfectures donc
comment va s'organiser s'organiser ce
lien avec les élus locaux dans la
revitalisation de nos villages et
ensuite ma dernière question j'ai pour
ma part l'honneur d'avoir été nommée au
conseil d'administration de la dame qui
renouvelle une expérience de coopération
dans son action avec la NCT et l'IGN le
rapport sénatorial proposé une institué
un comité de direction régulier commun
entre la NCT
cette coopération semble être une
solution pour tendre vers une plus
grande clarté transparence de
l'ingénierie comment comptez-vous
améliorer cette coopération et renforcer
le lien entre l'ingénierie et la
planification écologique indispensable
afin de sortir du simple appel à projets
et renouer avec une politique
d'aménagement du territoire cher au
structures qui vous ont précédé CGT data
même si tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
vous n'étiez pas la data
si on termine avec Jean-Claude Anglard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général
j'avais une question moi par rapport à
pour reprendre ce carrière la question
qui a posé Jean de Nicolaï par rapport
aux ânes vous savez c'est un sujet qui
préoccupe aujourd'hui sur tous les
territoires c'est d'ailleurs le premier
sujet qui préoccupe par tout en France
toutes les communes parce que elles sont
en train d'y travailler et dans le
dispositif je reviendrai pas sur ce que
nous avons fait ici dans la commission
spéciale et sur ce que nous attendons
aujourd'hui des décisions du
gouvernement sur le sujet puisque nous
avons voté ici une proposition de loi
sur ce sujet et nous attendons que les
députés n'est-ce pas bien se pencher sur
la question ma question donc elle est
sur la sobriété foncière et donc nous
avons applaudi nous avons approuvé
applaudi la mise en place du fond vert
du fond vert et avec la particularité
qu'il soit au même des préfets des
préfets de départements on considère que
pour dans la pour faire pour que la
sorbité foncière puisse se mettre en
place il faut effectivement surtout le
territoire et une prise de conscience
sur ce sujet c'est pour ça que la
politique petite ville de demain peut
être utile en dispositif et le fond vert
est un moyen sur le sujet je passe sur
ce dispositif Mathieu d'Arnaud l'a dit
quand on voit l'application aujourd'hui
il fond vert entre les préfets de
département et les préférés régionaux
c'est pas très clair du moins sur les
territoires voilà je fais la mais je
le redis aussi le rôle des préfets comme
missi dominici du sujet a été important
sur les territoires ruraux ma question
elle était par rapport à ce qu'a dit
Jean de Nicolas is sur l'étape
planificateur
puisque nous avons d'un côté donc le zan
qui se met en place avec 122000 hectares
à se répartir sur 10 ans enfin plutôt
100000 hectares puisqu'il faut enlever
22000 hectares dans l'enveloppe
nationale on sait pas où aller mais
mettons 1000 hectares donc où les
territoires effectivement vont
s'échapper sur la question à la fin
puisque quand on répartit l'enveloppe
c'est toujours compliqué et c'est le
sujet d'ailleurs actuel entre les
régions les scottes etc etc et de
l'autre côté nous avons 177000 hectares
de friches
et quand on pose la question mais est-ce
qu'on peut faire un rapprochement entre
les deux est-ce que les territoires
peuvent connaître ce que sont les
friches et est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
par exemple dans le schéma de
réindustrialisation de la France qui est
du point de végétal est à planificateur
qui disent ben voilà on a 177000
hectares de disponibles comment on fait
le rapprochement entre les deux voilà
alors c'est plus un avis que je vous
demande que un jugement mais c'est
vraiment une interrogation puisque
lorsqu'on pose cette question à toutes
les à toutes les structures on n'a pas
de réponse voilà si vous avez voilà
votre sentiment sur la question
merci monsieur le Président sur le les
conseillers numériques l'inclusion
numérique en général donc effectivement
sur la feuille de route qui a été
évoquée mais effectivement il y a
quelques semaines par le ministre
barreau moi je vous rejoins enfin
l'objectif de cette feuille de route
telle que moi je l'aperçois c'est aussi
de structurer toute une toute un tout un
écosystème qui a émergé de façon
extrêmement rapide qui était déjà
présent mais qui a connu un
développement extrêmement rapide avec la
période covid le passage à une
dématérialisation massive des
développements aussi une des
matérialisation des procédures et des
services qui d'ailleurs amène aussi à
réinvestir l'accueil physique à travers
son service aussi et c'est 2560 points
d'entrée aujourd'hui et pour rencontrer
du contact extrêmement nécessaire pour
une partie de notre population donc
c'est la question de comment structure
les choses et vos questions en fait
rejoignent un peu tous le hub la
désignation de la collectivité comme on
arrive territoire par territoire là où
il parfois foisonnante parfois peut-être
moins ont été mis en place comment on
arrive à les organiser concrètement
c'est aussi un sujet pour l'État et les
choses telles qu'elles sont cette
politique s'est déployée parfois sans
que même les services départementaux
régionaux maîtrise complètement ce qui
était porté par des fichiers associatifs
par des collectivités et on a besoin de
prendre un petit peu de temps pour
structurer la filière et la filière en
termes d'emploi la filière en termes de
compétences et aussi l'organisation et
l'accompagnement des publics donc là
dessus le travail c'est effectivement
au niveau régional et au niveau
départemental d'arriver à déterminer
alors forcément on sera pas dans la
législation donc dire qui est
coordinateur c'est qu'il y a un acteur
qui se positionne et que tout le monde
soit d'accord pour qu'il se positionne
pour étant l'acteur de l'animation mais
c'est toute cette démarche qui doit être
engagée au niveau régional avec des
référents et au niveau départemental
pour organiser la filière et trouver un
acteur qui souvent va émerger qui est
souvent là et qui prend un peu le lead
comme et pour porter la dynamique dans
un partenariat qui doit rester au niveau
local sur la question donc du fond
pluriannuel bon c'est des sujets qui
sont en train de se poser aujourd'hui
dans les débats budgétaires qui
commencent c'est encore un peu tôt pour
moi pour pouvoir apporter des réponses
mais effectivement on voit bien que et
c'est aussi la réponse sur la suite des
conseils numériques quel type
d'accompagnement sous quelle forme
l'État peut apporter sur ces questions
d'inclusion numérique on a mis des
moyens à travers le plan de relance
comment on se projette dans le temps il
est vrai aussi que c'est déjà
aujourd'hui des politiques partagées
c'est à dire que le Conseil numérique
est toujours cofinancé systématiquement
aujourd'hui donc c'est pas simplement
l'État c'est comment globalement le
collectivité publique s'organise avec
une par étape une part des collectivités
pour faire vivre cette filière donc on
est on est en construction et on voilà
on avance sur ces questions là avec
l'idée je vous dis vraiment de
structurer au niveau régional au niveau
départemental un positif qui aujourd'hui
est voilà il n'est pas complètement
peut-être structuré comme il le faudrait
surtout les territoires
sur la nationatrice bonne foi sur la
corniation avec l'ingénierie publique je
vous le disais tout à l'heure nous
l'objectif c'est la subsidiarité c'est
pas d'aller là où il y a déjà une
ingénierie qui répond besoin je constate
aussi ponctuellement qu'on peut aussi
avoir des territoires qui pour des
raisons diverses et variées souhaitent
passer par une prestation autre
extérieure différente moi on a
ponctuellement donc on essaye de pas
l'encourager du tout mais ça peut
arriver ponctuellement pour des raisons
y compris d'animosités locales il y a
besoin de trouver une solution il y a un
projet qui n'arrive pas à trouver sa
solution mais on est dans l'idée
d'intervenir que si il n'y a pas à
travers l'interface qu'il préfère et les
sous préfets des DT que s'il n'y a pas
de solution locale c'est à eux agence
technique syndicale et autres sur la
qualité des prestations privées des
marchés moi je ne suis pas négatif sur
le sujet parce que concrètement et pour
la revue sur le terrain y compris avec
des élus qui étaient avec leurs
prestataires pour présenter leurs
projets ils l'aurait pas fait s'ils
étaient pas content d'après-station il
me semble donc on a effectivement un
besoin d'avoir un haut niveau de qualité
et de services sur ces prestations
évidemment il faut que vous sachiez que
l'équipe précédente a fait résilier deux
marchés deux accords avec deux
prestataires sur la trentaine qui
n'étaient pas au niveau donc on a on est
on est dans un contrôle permanent pour
vérifier la qualité de service pour
éviter ce que vous évoquez les
copier-coller qui sont quand même loin
d'être le cas le plus courant à vrai
dire et puisque ce quand c'est le cas
évidemment on intervient et le cas
échéant on met fin au contrat s'il n'y a
pas le niveau on va renouveler
globalement le marché en 2024 il arrive
à échéance pour le faire de l'adapter
aussi aux besoins qu'on a vu émerger et
qui n'en ont des territoires il y a des
besoins qui notamment autour des
transitions qui sont beaucoup plus
nombreux il y a des
accompagnements peut-être plus
opérationnels qui sont nécessaires qui
sont pas forcément disponible sur tous
les territoires l'idée c'est d'offrir
une palette de services plus large
possible pour apporter cette réponse
adaptée à chacun des territoires s'il y
en a besoin en fait faut disposer de
toute la palette et puis s'il y a besoin
on on va piocher et puis s'il y en a pas
besoin on n'a pas recours sur le la
coordination avec Adam cérémy NCT bon
elle est prévue par le la loi d'abord on
a une convention 4 sur laquelle on
travaille on ne se voit tous les mois
dans des dans un conseil spécifique avec
aussi l'enru Lana parce que l'année est
un acteur très important aussi sur les
questions d'habitat et la banque des
territoires qu'un acteur aussi très
présent en matière d'ingénierie publique
sur les territoires et donc pour arriver
à travailler et nous travaillons aussi
notamment sur toutes les questions de
planification et de transition
écologique avec Adam et serréma sous
l'égide du ministre Béchu pour voilà
améliorer l'offre de service vis-à-vis
des territoires
et quand au moyen vous évoquez sur
France ruralité toute la démarche de
France ruralité c'est justement de
renforcer les services de l'État pour
accompagner aussi les territoires les
plus ruraux parce que c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui regardez-moi indisponible de
mener un accompagnement sur beaucoup
beaucoup de collectivités donc il faut
des renforts et c'est l'objectif de ce
plan notamment pour apporter ce soutien
plus petites communes
sur le sénateur anglar sur la question
du fond vert vous avez indiqué qu'il
pouvait y avoir des débats il est quand
même très très largement déconcentré au
niveau départemental ce qui est
parfaitement cohérent à notre propre
organisation à la DETR à la mise en
oeuvre concret de la décile et c'est
vrai que c'est quand même l'objectif de
donner au préfet département le plus de
leviers à sa main pour vous rapporter
des réponses au territoire alors
effectivement ça peut créer des silos de
financement un peu distincts parce
qu'ils ont été créés dans différentes
périodes avec différentes vocations
néanmoins l'objectif c'est que le préfet
de département puisse arriver à trouver
les solutions en utilisant ces
différentes enveloppes sur la
planification vous avez d'abord l'étape
planificateur c'est intéressant que ça
revienne encore une nouvelle fois vous
avez eu raison préciser que les outils
planification d'aménagement territoire
aujourd'hui prenons le premier d'entre
eux qu'elle sera dette il est élaboré
par les Conseils Régionaux
rappelons-nous c'est législateur qui l'a
prévu ainsi et qui va ensuite
intervaliscott et les plu donc on va
avoir toute une gamme voilà descendante
et on le voit sur le zan le dispositif
stradette conférence des scottes Scott
plu c'est cette ce cette cascade qui
arrive sur les territoires cette
organisation fait une partie de la
planification territoriale est
aujourd'hui portée animée par les
collectivités et c'est logique dans une
république centralisée 40 ans après les
premières lois vous soulevez un point
essentiel avec le sujet des friches et
d'usane globalement l'enjeu et moi je
constate en allant notamment sur les
programmes qui passait V etc qui l'ont
mis en oeuvre mais ça commence à
apparaître sur d'autres territoires
c'est la mobilisation sur les friches il
faut effectivement réutiliser des
friches d'habitat des friches activités
commerciales ou industrielles c'est déjà
engagé moi je constate juste me déplace
je vois les élus l'ont le mettre en
oeuvre notamment dans les coeurs de
ville ou dans les centres-villes c'est
indispensable si vous voulez refaire de
l'attractivité de centre-ville il faut
que vous rem de l'habitant et du
commerce dans le centre-ville et vous
arrêtiez ces phénomènes où vous avez
parfois 20% 30% de vacances de logements
sur les cordes ou les centres bourgs
donc c'est un enjeu fondamental enjeu
d'habitat plus que parfois que
simplement de d'activités commerciales
et c'est de la friche si on considère
parfois ces mêmes quasiment ruines et on
a des territoires des terrains aussi qui
sont des vrais friches plutôt
industriels et artisanales sur lesquels
il faut réinvestir concrètement et moi
je vois sur la réflexion sur les entrées
de villes vous savez que ces actions de
ville 2 toute la réflexion portée par
certains territoires qui se concentrent
sur ces espaces là avec des
potentialités extrêmement intéressantes
parce que souvent assez bien situé
souvent déjà dans la ville dans le tissu
urbain donc pas besoin de créer de la
voirie pas besoin de créer des réseaux
de mobilité tout est déjà là ou des
réseaux tout court mais simplement il
faut arriver à trouver la réponse et le
traitement de la friche le projet qu'on
met dessus son intégration son aspect de
transition notamment dans la
construction et c'est toute une
réflexion sur effectivement la
construction de la ville mais vous
pointez du doigt l'enjeu majeur et moi
j'ai le sentiment qui peut être relevé
il est en train d'être relevé dans mon
monde de territoires
merci dernière série Jean-Michel
Houlgate
merci oui donc Monsieur le Directeur
Général merci monsieur le Président le
sujet du numérique a été largement à
aborder par certains collègues vous
l'avez souligné donc le plan France très
haut débit donc continuez à se déployer
donc à un rythme élevé pour généraliser
la fibre notamment afin 2025 vous avez
signalé dans un certain nombre de
disparités la NCT a pris une initiative
l'initiative de lancer deux audits un
premier audit sur la qualité des
infrastructures qui sont déployées pour
le compte des collectivités et puis un
deuxième audit sur le pilotage des des
projets notamment ce qu'on pourrait
appeler un audit organisationnel sur la
fois sur la gestion de projet sur les
financements et ainsi de suite quels
sont je dirais les sous-entendus par
rapport notamment à ces deux audits et
est-ce que déjà sans en avoir les
résultats vous envisagez des actions qui
pourraient des actions correctives pour
accompagner les collectivités puisque on
sait très bien que la loi de Pareto va
faire que c'est les 20%
de couverture finaux qui seront
nécessaires et qui nécessiteront donc
une énergie
importante donc quels sont je dirais les
arrières pensées de la NCT au-delà de
ces audits
merci ronanantec oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
de questions la première donc le Conseil
national de la transition écologique
hôtel à l'unanimité donc des nations de
protection de l'environnement à la FNSEA
un avis demandant au gouvernement de
mettre l'action publique en ordre de
marche sur un + 4 degrés d'augmentation
des températures moyennes en France
métropolitaine dans le Coran du XXIe
siècle donc qu'est-ce que et c'est un
gros enjeu de cohésion des territoires
et soutient l'ingénierie des petits
territoires donc qu'est-ce que la NCT en
lien évidemment avec de ces Adem est en
ordre de bataille sur ce qui va
profondément modifier
l'évaluation de l'action publique et de
l'investissement de long terme en France
première question deuxième question le
signe tankai forcer qui est très proche
de la Caisse des dépôts qui sont
principales financières
considèrent que on a parlé fond vert on
a parlé
CRPE il manque à peu près 25000
personnes en ingénierie territoriale
pour mener à bien la transition
écologique sur les territoires 25000
personnes c'est beaucoup c'est assez
cohérent avec ce que le Sénat a voté
plusieurs fois à l'unanimité qui est une
dotation de fonctionnement climat pour
les collectivités qui pourraient être
une partie du fond vert qui reste
malheureusement plutôt fléchés à
investissement alors que c'est plutôt
l'ingénierie qui manque donc qu'est-ce
que vous ne pensez pas que plutôt que
avoir un état qui est un peu au coup par
coup projet par projet fourni de
l'ingénierie au territoire il serait pas
mieux de passer un cap et d'avoir un
financement pérenne pour les territoires
et créer une vraie une génériorité
territoriale de transition écologique
qui manque cruellement aujourd'hui et
est-ce que dans ce cas-là NCT n'aurait
pas un rôle plus efficace en finalement
étant un accompagneur un accompagnateur
de l'émergence de cette fonction
publique territoriale dont nous avons
nous allons avoir de plus en plus besoin
merci on termine avec Nadège avait
merci
je reviendrai sur l'accès aux fonciers
qui est un enjeu fort vous venez de le
rappeler dans ce cadre un rapport a été
publié sur la fabrique prospective et
sur les sites industriels de demain un
des conseils de ce rapport pour mieux
gérer le foncier industriel préconise
l'élaboration d'un schéma stratégique et
de développement des sites industriels à
l'échelle intercommunale j'aimerais en
savoir plus sur le contenu et les
attendus de ce schéma je vous remercie
d'avoir souligné ces travaux qui ont été
engagés qui sont le fruit des échanges
réguliers avec les partenaires
collectivités qui portent le déploiement
on a deux on a effectivement des
problèmes qu'on partageait localement
avec deux aspects que vous avez pointé
un parfois d'infrastructures déjà
réalisé mais dont la qualité est pas
totalement là et en fait c'est le
prestataire enfin l'opéra
fait ce qu'il fallait forcément donc on
a des sujets de qualité sur les zones
argentantes sur lesquelles il faut il
faut parfois s'interroger avant que ce
soit trop tard y compris pour essayer de
faire corriger le tir par ces maîtres
d'oeuvre et puis on a le sujet en termes
de de d'organisation le pays le pilotage
de projet parce qu'on sait que dans
certains territoires il y a une
dynamique moins rapide que dans d'autres
qui est lié à une organisation qui a
peut-être mis du temps à s'installer
notre objectif n'est pas de du doigt des
difficultés il est bien normal que vu la
vitesse à laquelle s'est déployée ses
opérations y est quand même quelques
difficultés ce serait même étonnant que
ce soit pas le cas mais il vaut mieux
les identifier maintenant avant qu'on
arrive au terme du programme et que tout
soit enfoui et les opérateurs tous
partis et qu'on arrive à rectifier le
tir dès maintenant donc les audits sont
vraiment logiques d'accompagnement c'est
vraiment ça se fait avec les
collectivités compétentes dans une
démarche d'accompagnement pour leur
permettre aussi d'avancer
vis-à-vis de leur prestataire et
vis-à-vis le cas échéant leur
organisation s'il faut faire évoluer les
choses donc oui derrière l'idée c'est
qu'on puisse en tirer des conclusions
mais des conclusions partagées pour
faire avancer et pour améliorer en fait
la réponse c'est pas du tout du contrôle
c'est de l'accompagnement on le conçoit
vraiment comme ça et se mettre en appui
pour permettre aux collectivités de
trouver une une réponse sur les
difficultés qu'elles peuvent rencontrer
soit avec leur prestataires soit dans
leur organisation pour mettre mettre en
oeuvre le déploiement de la fibre
sur la question de des sujets sur
l'ingénierie sur la transition je ne
sais pas s'il faut 25000 personnes en
tous les cas ce que je peux vous
indiquer c'est que dans le fond vert il
y a une enveloppe d'ingénierie vous le
savez qui a été réservée de 25 millions
d'euros qui a été mis en œuvre cette
année plus globalement c'est toute la
réflexion je l'indiquais d'ailleurs dans
quelques minutes le ministre béchure
réunit les associations d'élus aussi sur
ces questions de comment on s'organise
collectivement pour faire face aux
enjeux de la transition je l'ai indiqué
que c'est une un élément clé de notre
feuille de route aussi à l'agence on
travaille avec le céréma avec l'ADEME
évidemment sur ces questions et comment
nous aussi tous nos outils je pense
parler du marché je parlais aussi de des
programmes que sur lesquels on émet
d'ouvrage comment ils intègrent encore
plus cette dimension
je vous disais aussi beaucoup de
territoires ont déjà engagé ces travaux
et ses réflexions et avec des chefs de
projet qui ont pu permettre aux élus de
formaliser des réflexions donc on a
quand même des territoires qui sont pas
tous au même niveau d'avancement il faut
effectivement embarquer tout le monde et
là-dessus évidemment l'agence à mon sens
un rôle à jouer d'abord par son maillage
son appui sur le réseau des services de
l'État départementaux sa proximité avec
bon nombre d'acteurs territoriaux et sa
capacité aussi à faire entendre des des
mécaniques qui sont pas toujours
évidentes à
appréhender pour le dans tous les
territoires parce que parfois ça fait
plus peur et ça fait peur et les gens
s'arrêtent plutôt que face à l'obstacle
essayez de trouver des solutions donc
évidemment qu'on est à disposition et je
suis pas du tout inquiet sur le le défi
de lancement durable sur le question du
fond vert ça a été indiqué par la
première ministre mais au-delà sur
l'ingénierie d'accompagnement aux
transition avoir après l'ampleur mais en
tous les cas je suis tout à fait
convaincu on aura des moyens pour
avancer sur la question du schéma
stratégique sur les sites industriels
madame la sénatrice alors je peux pas
vous faire une réponse spécifique
là-dessus sur cette proposition en
revanche vous dire que la réflexion pour
nous à travers l'annonce sur le relance
de territoire industrie c'est de
réfléchir sur deux axes indonés à tous
les territoires industries les moyens en
ingénierie pour pouvoir là aussi porter
une dynamique territoriale en termes de
réindustrialisation en termes de
développement de formation de de porter
la connaissance et d'attractivité du
territoire en matière industrielle et
deuxième aspect de disposer de
financement d'investissement pour
accompagner les projets de
réindustrialisation sur ces territoires
donc on est évidemment on s'inscrit dans
la démarche plus globale qui est France
2030 bien sûr qui doit qui vise à
développer les industries de demain mais
on a aussi à consolider les industries
qu'on a aujourd'hui dans les territoires
qui peuvent être parfois en difficulté
parfois qui sont engagés dans la
transition qui ont besoin qu'on les aide
à franchir des étapes clés et évidemment
on sera au rendez-vous et je sais pas si
c'est un schéma stratégique exactement
mais en tous les cas l'idée c'est d'être
au bon niveau région interco-état sur
les territoires industries vraiment
actifs au plus près du terrain pour
faire avancer les dossiers portés par
ces industriels
merci une ultime question sur les élèves
oui merci monsieur le Président juste
une en collaboration avec Rémi Pointreau
une question sur les intérêts après les
ânes ce sont les élèves la coalition de
l'aménagement du territoire et durable à
publier en avril dernier rapport
d'information sur ce sujet et nous
proposons notamment un passage de la
maille intercommunale à la maille
communale pour le classement ZRR afin
d'apprécier plus finement la ruralité
par ailleurs le rapport suggère
également d'augmenter le nombre de
critères permettant d'apprécier le
classement aux etre afin de tenir compte
de la diversité des ruralités qu'elle
regarde portez-vous sur ses propositions
de réforme et dans le contexte de cette
mission d'information nous avons
interrogé de nombreux élus qui ont
évoqués un problème de visibilité des
érr de nombreux potentiels bénéficiaires
et
ignore l'existence de ce dispositif
alors que les services de l'État
communiquent pas sur les urinations
fiscales que permet ce zonage et dans le
cas de la prochaine feuille de route
gouvernementale en cours de préparation
serait-il selon vous au porta d'ajouter
aux missions de la NCT la promotion des
zones de revitation rurale pourront
renforcer l'efficacité alors que ce
jeune âge contribue par définition à la
cohésion le territoire par son effet de
rééquilibrage
sur ce point effectivement dans la
réflexion plus globalement sur dans le
ce qu'on appelle France ruralité c'est
la ministre fort présente François
réalité il y a plusieurs niveaux il y a
une stature des mesures
interministérielles questions culture de
santé de logement de mobilité il y a la
strate derrière sur la joie et puis il y
a le dispositif de programme
d'accompagnement sur les plus petites
communes avec de l'ingénierie des tasses
et ce qui est évoqué il y a encore
quelques instants sur la strate ZRR vous
voyez qu'on le présentant dans ce format
là c'est clairement aussi lui apporter
une visibilité plus forte que simplement
un article du PLF qui provoque d'un an
un dispositif exonération fiscale ce
sera quand même présenté dans un paquet
global avec toute une réflexion
effectivement sur les zonages avec voilà
en prenant en compte les territoires qui
sont aussi peut-être les plus en
difficulté je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
de consultations et de concertation qui
ont été engagés sur cette question et
concrètement moi je suis assez confiant
sur le fait que cette on a cette
configuration on va mettre en oeuvre ce
programme transtrualité en même temps
que le zonage va être renouvelé donc
cette présentation en paquet global pour
valoriser toute cette action via des
territoires qu'ils en est mieux
conscience sera plus simple parce que ça
arrivera en même moment donc je j'ai le
sentiment que ce sera effectivement
utile pour les territoires parce que
certains n'ont pas bien connaissance
d'autres savent qu'ils sont ces
dernières retiennent vraiment y rester
on le sait mais on a quand même intérêt
aussi à faire mieux connaître ses
exonérations à partir du moment où le
dispositif est totalement finalisé
très bien merci Monsieur le Directeur
général on va passer à la deuxième
partie de la matinée sur la table ronde
et je vais rendre ma place au président
bien
mes chers collègues on va on va
commencer le deuxième point de l'ordre
du jour parce que on doit libérer la
salle pour 11h pour la commission des
lois voilà
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons nos
auditions consacrées
[Musique]
après avoir entendu plutôt ce matin le
directeur général de la NCT St Stanislas
Bouron et je remercie encore Guillaume
Chevrollier et Louis Jean de Nicolay
d'avoir été présent ce matin il apparaît
ainsi naturellement de recueillir la vie
et la vision des acteurs intéressés au
premier chef par l'action de lagence à
savoir les associations des
collectivités alors que que lors de
l'examen de par notre commission de la
proposition de loi relative à l'ancien
en 2019 nous avions insisté sur la
nécessité de créer agence pour les
collectivités qui sont et doivent rester
au premier plan de la cohésion des
territoires plutôt qu'une agence de
l'État déconcentré avant toute chose et
de matières générales je souhaiterais
entendre votre point de vue sur l'action
de la NCT
l'agence a-t-elle répondu à vos attentes
concernant d'une part les différents
programmes portés comme action cœur de
ville ou petite ville de demain ou
d'autre part l'offre d'ingénierie
territoriale pourriez-vous nous livrer
votre opinion sur la présence de
l'agence sur notre territoire le rapport
de la délégation collectivité
territoriale sur le bilan de la NT a
pointé une certaine absence des
délégations territoriales de lagence
dirigé par le préfet qui est le
représentant de l'ancter dans le
département alors que cette présence
territoriale trop modeste est à
l'origine d'un manque de visibilité et
de notoriété de l'agence serait-il selon
vous souhaitable de déléguer ce rôle de
représentant territoriale à un
sous-préfet capable d'incarner plus
concrètement l'anct sur nos territoires
je souhaiterais également vous
interroger sur vos attentes concernant
la deuxième feuille de route de la NCT
pour la période 2023 2026 êtes-vous
favorable aux premières orientations
présentées par la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités terriales et de
la ruralité Dominique Faure en avril
dernier
alors que les élus municipaux arriveront
le mois prochain à mi-mandat souhaité
vous une stabilité dans l'action de la
NCT ou au contraire est-il selon vous
nécessaire d'orienter l'action de
l'agence dans une nouvelle direction
si une nouvelle impulsion devait être
donnée quel en serait selon vous les
principaux axes à privilégiés avant de
laisser la parole à l'ensemble de mes
collègues pour vous interroger à leur
tour je vous cède la parole madame
monsieur pour répondre à quelques points
je vous remercie et je vous remercie
encore de votre présence
madame monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames
peut-être en quelques mots pour
commencer à répondre à vos à vos sujets
et interrogations
d'abord préciser qu'intercommunalité de
France a soutenu la création de l'agence
au moment des débats parlementaires ça
nous semblait intéressant d'avoir une
évolution du CGT et puis un
rapprochement des différentes agences et
opérateurs de l'État
peut-être d'abord souligner ce qui
marche selon nous au sein de la NCT
en premier lieu les programmes que sont
actions cœur de ville territoire
d'industrie petite ville de demain est
encore un programme très jeune et
difficilement évaluables mais en ce qui
concerne les deux premiers et la feuille
de route pour la deuxième étape d'action
cœur de ville nous semble intéressant
puisqu'elle permet de dépasser le cœur
de ville pour essayer de se mettre dans
une dispositif un peu plus
intercommunale puisqu'on voit bien que
traiter par exemple le commerce
uniquement dans une logique de d'une
ville assez limite puisque toute la la
cohérence avec le commerce de périphérie
etc doit également être appréhendé donc
cette évolution d'action cœur de ville
nous semble intéressantes en ce qui
concerne territoire d'industrie mais j'y
reviendrai là aussi l'évolution du
programme qui a été annoncé par le
président de la République la semaine
dernière nous sommes également une une
bonne piste à reprendre plusieurs de nos
de nos propositions
de façon plus transversale ce qui nous
semble intéressant dans les programmes
ce sont les chefs de projet toute la
chef frite projet qui a été mise en
place par la NCT est intéressante et ça
reprend un certain nombre de remarques
qui ont été qui ont été réalisés par les
par les sénateurs présents ce matin tout
à l'heure
l'autre point qui nous semble être
intéressant dans l'action de la NCT
concerne l'accompagnement entre
guillemets sur mesure qui a pu être
réalisé à Béthune ou à Tulle en lien
avec la désindustrialisation de ces de
ces territoires avec là aussi une
ingénérique qui a été mis à disposition
du territoire concerné mais sur du moyen
terme nous ne sommes pas dans de
l'action comme ce qui est lié au marché
à bon de commande de la NCT de façon
très ponctuelle qu'il a nous semble
avoir des effets beaucoup plus limités
en termes d'amélioration trois points
d'abord le lien entre ces programmes
beaucoup d'élus nous font remonter une
action très en silo action qui
reviennent d'un côté territoire
d'industrie de l'autre petite ville de
demain France ruralité
demain également qui va qui va arriver
il y a certainement une mise en relation
à faire entre ces programmes pour éviter
aussi une segmentation des territoires
sur le sur le terrain
autre point d'amélioration certainement
dans les mois qui viennent la difficulté
de mobiliser la NCT sur le terrain c'est
quelque chose qui revient très
fréquemment vous l'avez souligné à
plusieurs reprises une difficulté
d'identification de l'agence qui revient
très très fréquemment
la désignation des sous-préfets comme
comme représentant de la NCT dans les
territoires pourraient certainement être
une piste intéressante en tout cas en
l'état les choses ne sont pas ne sont
pas forcément très très pertinentes et
le lien avec l'échelle régionale peut
également être être creusé là aussi ça a
été souligné ces derniers mois la NCT a
été vu dans une logique très
départementale or les financements sont
souvent régionalisés donc il y a
certainement une articulation d'échelle
à penser sans remettre en cause la
représentation de la NCT à l'échelle
départementale une articulation des
échelles à repenser et troisième piste
d'amélioration l'ingénierie proposée
je le disais tout à l'heure le marché
abonde commande la NCT souvent
vu de façon assez négative par les élus
locaux parce que on fait du saupoudrage
on est sur du court terme alors que ce
qu'on demande nous c'est plutôt de ligne
générique de long terme de ligne
générique projet où on a des chefs de
projets qui s'installent dans un
territoire qui connaissent les acteurs
et qui sont capables de faire de
l'animation du développement local en
résumé donc quatre propositions si vous
me le permettez monsieur le Président
d'abord peut-être une meilleure
coordination des chefs de projet il y a
certainement des synergies à mettre en
place une animation de ces chefs frites
projets à repenser et peut-être pas
forcément uniquement dans une logique
nationale comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
mais aussi dans une logique régionale ça
pourrait être extrêmement intéressant
puisqu'on parle de stradettes on parle
de SRD E2i d'avoir une animation à cette
à cet échec là pour faire du benchmark
de la du passage de témoin etc ça
pourrait être extrêmement intéressant
deuxième point
la meilleure coordination des services
de l'État la NCT pour nous avait un
intérêt lors de sa création parce
qu'elle devait permettre cette meilleure
coordination cette meilleure
articulation on a beaucoup parlé au
moment de la loi 3DS ce préfet
coordinateur des services des concentrés
de l'État la NCT être au service de cela
on n'y est pas encore on n'est pas
encore et là il y a quelque chose à
creuser à ce niveau là
l'interministérialité peut être peut
être une vraie source de gain apporté
par la NCT et c'est en cela que la
nouvelle génération de crpe pourrait
être un très bon levier
d'abord d'interministérialité et de plus
réanualité il serait dommage que la
nctvienne dans les territoires que de
façon ponctuelle et ne se mette pas dans
une logique de développement des
territoires on parlait transitions
écologique tout à l'heure on peut parler
de transition numérique de transition
démographique les enjeux qui sont face à
nous sont des enjeux de long terme il
serait dommage que la nctvienne que dans
une logique de court terme donc
interministérialité plus réanualité ce
sont des enjeux extrêmement des enjeux
extrêmement forts et puis
dernier point
la NCT pas vocation à être la data mais
renforcer l'Observatoire et le rôle
d'aménagement du territoire de cette
agence nous semblerait être une piste
intéressante quand on parle de
planification écologique même de zan les
enjeux de sobriété foncière nous
obligent à nous mettre dans une logique
d'aménagement du territoire beaucoup
plus important que ça a été le cas
aujourd'hui
et l'Observatoire de la NCT mériterait
d'être musclé à cette à cet égard
et voir
de d'être renforcé sur le volet européen
aujourd'hui les collectivités locales et
les associations d'élus ne sont pas
encore assez outillés pour prendre en
compte les enjeux européens en termes
d'alerte sur ce qui se passe sur ce qui
est voté à Bruxelles on sait que ça
arrive dans les territoires plusieurs
mois plus tard voir au Parlement et il
n'y a pas assez de mobilisation de
l'agence de notre point de vue à ce à ce
niveau là et il est très difficile
aujourd'hui d'avoir du benchmark à
l'échelle européenne alors qu'on aurait
certainement beaucoup à apprendre mais
on voit bien que du côté de la banque
des territoires côté des associations
d'élus côté de la NCT on n'est pas
encore assez assez musclé sur ce sur ce
niveau là donc de notre point de vue la
NCT pourrait aussi avoir un rôle sur
cette sur cette échelle là voilà en
propos liminaire ce sinon je voulais
vous faire par monsieur le président
bonjour messieurs dames monsieur le
président
on partage un privilège avec avec ma
collègue ma voisine c'est que on anime
des réseaux de gens qui font et donc
notre propos il est aussi de dire la NCT
on la voit dans sa capacité à pouvoir
répondre à une dynamique à des
dynamiques de territoire et
effectivement on va très vite dans le
coeur du débat pour dire où est-ce que
elle répond à cette envie d'agir des
élus à l'échelle communale pour ce qui
nous concerne
soit par subsidiarité choisi soit avant
de déléguer sur des espaces mutualisés
ce qui nous intéresse nous aujourd'hui
dans cette dans votre questionnement
c'est de voir que premièrement c'est un
outil indispensable à l'échelle
nationale pour pouvoir donner une forme
de cohérence à un certain nombre de
politiques publiques et je reviendrai
tout à l'heure sur en quoi elles sont un
certain titre notamment utile et à
d'autres sur lequel il y a encore
énormément de choses à faire évoluer
notamment au bénéfices de du
développement du territoire euros et
puis votre deuxième chapitre sur la
question de l'ingénierie qui est la plus
tôt la question du premier maître comme
le président
fournit le disait il y a quelques jours
à la première ministre cette question là
de l'ingénierie concrète ou
effectivement on est très très loin du
compte dans la question de pouvoir
identifier à la fois
un opérateur nouveau alors que les mers
ont l'habitude de travailler depuis
longtemps avec leur sous-préfet et de
l'autre côté de voir la nécessité de de
démultiplier les solutions par rapport à
là encore une fois l'envie de faire
beaucoup de nos élus à tel point
d'ailleurs que notre association a été
amenée nous à créer aussi une forme de
service d'ingénierie et qui est
extrêmement intéressant dans ce qu'il
montre dans ses capacités à orienter et
c'est si nous nous sommes amenés à le
faire ça veut dire que localement sur le
terrain cette question là n'est pas
réglé et c'est un point important aussi
dans la dans la dimensionnement de
l'agence sur les programmes nationaux
nous très clairement
le président Fournier qui est également
vice-président de la NTT
plaid pour la création d'un troisième
programme village d'avenir pourquoi
parce que l'agence encore une fois avec
l'avantage qu'elle a de superviser un
salon de politique fait de l'aménagement
du territoire mais elle n'en fait pas
telle que nous nous l'imaginons
souhaitable savoir un aménagement des
territoires beaucoup plus équilibré si
vous ajoutez le nombre de communes PVD
et le nombre de communes quart de ville
s'il reste 94% des communes qui n'ont
pas de programme et donc sans aller sur
à ce que toutes les communes rurales
soient éligibles à un nouveau programme
cette question du village d'avenir cette
question de l'accompagnement même si ça
a été souligné et par les collègues lors
de l'intervention précédente du
directeur général de la NCT
il y a des il y a des manquements sur
PVD mais c'est vécu localement comme
quelque chose qui vient à la fois
apporter une ingénierie donc qui nous
manque et d'autre part il faut pas
sous-estimer aussi l'effet que ça de
focaliser la tension la Sodome
d'opérateurs vous allez citer la banque
des territoires le cérémy etc qui
privilégie et qui accentue leur
intervention sur les villages PVD et
coeur de ville et donc mécaniquement
n'accompagne pas forcément suffisamment
les autres territoires et donc à partir
de là il y a une question de
déséquilibre et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
est très fortement mobilisé pour faire
évoluer pour rééquilibrer cet
aménagement du territoire à l'intérieur
de la question à l'intérieur de l'Agence
notamment il y a un indicateur qui est
extrêmement simple là-dessus on sait que
l'histoire de l'agence ça a été aussi la
fusion d'un certain nombre d'opérateurs
et la disproportion en termes de
personnel mobilisés au sein de l'agence
au bénéfice des questions du quartier
politique de la ville versus la chétive
mais méritoire et dynamique équipe de
ruralité montagne où ils sont royalement
5 il y a un problème de disproportion si
on veut faire vraiment le plan France
ruralité après avoir fait la gendar
rurale la question elle est forcément
aussi une question d'allocation de
moyens à l'échelle nationale je viendrai
tout à l'heure sur la dimension
de l'ingénierie sur la partie nationale
aussi un des bienfaits de cette agence
c'est qu'elle est aujourd'hui des
positaire de la nouvelle définition de
la ruralité ce qui est une conquête
collective même si on y est forcément
pour quelque chose aujourd'hui il faut
que cette nouvelle définition elle
prospère et qu'elle infuse partout et
effectivement c'est bien qu'une agence
nationale et cette capacité encore
faut-il qu'elle puisse la matérialiser
pour pouvoir faire que tous les
ministres collègues parlaient
d'interministérialité tous les
ministères utilisent la bonne définition
et notamment aujourd'hui la définition
de l'Insee qui est très loin d'être le
cas donc là aussi elle a aussi un
travail important de diffusion
dissémination de cette notion là sur les
programmes nationaux on retrouve un
petit peu ce sans doute cette cette
capacité à pouvoir faire évoluer un
certain nombre de dispositif pour
justement les ruraliser pour dire les
choses de manière un peu plus un peu
plus simple il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
ceux qui existent sont nés ou sont le
fruit de l'histoire pour lesquels la
réalité est pas forcément le le point
central de l'entrée sur sur l'ingénierie
comment dire les choses les les mers
euros savent depuis très longtemps qui
faut appeler la question c'est est-ce
qu'ils ont du temps et des moyens pour
le faire c'est le sous-préfet ils ont
tous leur numéro de portable la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire de
manière concrète nous j'attire votre
attention sur un point ça a été évoqué
aussi par influence sur la question de
l'ingénierie sur mesure on a une
difficulté à appréhender la linéarité
entre les stimuli locaux les demandes
opérées par nos collectivités locales et
ce qui est ensuite présenté comme ayant
été retenu dans le comité notamment à
l'occasion des conseils d'administration
on a vu pour ce qui concerne les
communes rurales une évolution très
positive parce qu'au départ il y avait
quasiment pas de comme une rurale
retenue aujourd'hui on est à peu près à
peu près 50% des des territoires qui
sont aidés qui sont des communes rurales
donc c'est une réponse nouvelle et
positive je rappelle aussi qu'on avait
été la seule association a demandé à ce
que cette prestation soit assumée
financièrement au bénéfice gratuitement
au bénéfice des communes rurales donc
c'est cette évolution là elle est
notoire et elle est positive mais il
reste que en termes d'évaluation on a
une difficulté et je pense que on n'est
pas les seuls à mesurer est-ce que il y
a 500 sollicitations à l'échelle locale
ou si on a 10 et donc cette question là
il faudra peut-être la documenter de
manière plus forte et ensuite la
question c'est l'agencement
des opérateurs d'ingénierie je pense
qu'on raisonne dans une logique qui
avait sans doute bien fondée de l'anct
dans sa linéarité de des acteurs de
l'État mais je pense qu'au milieu rural
comme ailleurs
la question de la coalition avec les
autres solutions de d'ingénierie on a
beaucoup parlé c'est normal des agences
départementales mais il y en a pas
partout mais il y a aussi de
l'ingénierie qui est peut-être pas
forcément coordonné connu et peut-être
que les sous-préfets si on est dans le
champ des propositions peut-être que les
sous préfets pourraient être eux
détenteurs de de liste d'opérateurs qui
à l'échelle locale sont capables de
répondre de manière simple à des
commandes simples et ça aujourd'hui je
pense que ça ça renforcerait la densité
d'ingénierie accessible et connu des
territoires ruraux alors qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une forme de d'invisibilité de
ces opérateurs là donc c'est c'est pour
nous des points importants sur ces
questions là je veux pas forcément vont
être beaucoup plus longs dans ces propos
là juste dire aussi peut-être là-dessus
parmi les pistes on a évidemment lu avec
attention et on avait contribué
positivement avec avec votre votre la
mission d'information le rapport
d'information il y a j'attire votre
attention sur par exemple une des
briques complémentaires que j'évoquais à
l'instant pour être aussi la question de
la réserve citoyenne
il y a c'est l'article 11 de la loi et
je me souviens qu'à l'époque quand on
quand la loi était publiée quand on a
dit nous ça nous paraît intéressant
parce que par exemple dans les
territoires heureux vous le savez il y a
des gens qui sont passionnés par
l'action publique et qui resteront même
s'ils sont plus élus par exemple je
prends les anciens maires ils sont à la
disposition et souvent ils ont un
rapport bienveillant à leurs collègues
aujourd'hui quand on avait interrogé
l'état il nous avait dit on n'a pas fait
on n'a pas pris de décret au motif que
ça n'était pas forcément une idée qui
venait de l'administration centrale mais
qui venait du Parlement donc peut-être
que il y a peut-être quelque chose à
aller pousser là-dessus pour pouvoir
traduire dans la dans les fêtes un
article de la loi qui aujourd'hui est
sans effet voilà pour mes premiers
propos
merci tous les deux pour ces propos
liminaire je vais donner la parole à
Louis-Jean de Nicolas merci merci
monsieur le Président mais dans les
questions posées l'essentiel des
questions sont là en fait sur le sur la
NCT moi je suis membre du Conseil
administration de la NCT avec différents
collègues je disais tout à l'heure au
directeur général que je trouve que
alors que les fonctionnaires d'État se
font remplacés par des collègues lorsque
ils ne peuvent pas aller au Conseil
administration les élus n'ont pas le
droit de se faire remplacer par d'autres
collègues je pense que ça sera une
question à poser dans l'évolution de NCT
pour permettre une véritable
représentation des des élus au conseil
d'amiation et ainsi apporter si je puis
dire leur pied leur pièce la pierre
utile elle édifice moi je je rejoins les
propos que vous avez posé les questions
que vous avez posé madame sur notamment
le le rôle des régions
la coordination entre l'État et les
régions
je ne la sens pas du tout au niveau de
l'agence nationale que dans les
territoires et on la sent encore moins
sur la porte que pourrait apporter les
fonctions structurelles dans
l'aménagement du territoire au niveau
des communes moyennes ou des petites
communes donc c'est des fonds structurés
maintenant qui sont gérés par les
régions elles en font à juste titre
certainement très bon usages mais nous
je pense que dans le dans le cas de du
travail de la de l'agence au niveau de
des politiques publiques communes ça
serait utile d'avoir un rapprochement un
peu plus important avec avec la RF pour
pour permettre pour permettre de
bénéficier des défenses structures
européens notamment à partir à partir de
2007 moi j'ai une question essentielle
sur le rôle des comités de coordination
locaux à l'instar des préfets sur le
fonctionnement de la NCT sur les
politiques que peut mettre en place la
NCT sur les territoires est-ce que vous
savez comment ça se passe sur vos
territoires nous c'est je prends
l'exemple de mon département qui est
suivi de la Sarthe c'est une fois par an
où le préfet ou le délété annonce ce que
la NCT apportait comme soutien à
l'ensemble des territoires mais c'est
pas de la coordination c'est de
l'explication c'est la présentation d'un
dossier a joué savoir un peu comment
vous voyez les choses à la fois soit
dans les communes rurales soit au niveau
de l'intercommunalité comment vous voyez
les choses sur sur le fonctionnement de
ces comités est-ce que vous êtes
satisfait ou ce que vous n'êtes pas
merci et je vais faire couper les
réponses comme ça si vous
je vais donner la parole à Hervé gilet
merci monsieur le Président
merci pour vos remarques et vos
interventions qui me semblent
particulièrement
judicieux je voudrais revenir sur
l'organisation en fait
de la mise en œuvre de l'ingénierie
territoriale au bénéfice de l'ensemble
de vos structures pour essayer peut-être
de regarder comment elle pourrait être
beaucoup mieux organisée et mise en
oeuvre au regard de la nature de vos
projets parce que j'ai le sentiment que
même si on affirme un guichet par le
biais des sous-préfets ça ne suffira pas
ça ne suffira pas à répondre de manière
qualitative à l'accompagnement ciblé en
fonction de la nature des projets et ça
ne suffira pas à mobiliser ce que
j'appelle moi une forme de groupement de
compétences qui dans l'idéal devrait
regrouper les compétences d'État les
compétences des régions et les
compétences des départements
ce qui est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que pour
vraiment accompagner un vrai projet
territorial aujourd'hui si on était
vraiment dans une démarche idéale il
faudrait avoir ce groupement de
compétences qui permet d'accompagner au
mieux
les projets dans leur recherche de
financement et dans leur mise en œuvre
les syndicats mixtes au territoriaux
parfois par le biais de l'approche
contractuelle le permette on met autour
de la table l'ensemble de l'ingénierie
qui est conventionnée au travers des
projets territoire via des syndicats qui
portent des politiques de pays
contractualisés avec la région ou autre
donc c'est une clé d'entrée elle est pas
unique parce que tous les territoires
sont pas organisés de la même manière
mais la clé d'entrée sur les syndicats
mixtes territoriaux est intéressantes
pour mieux mettre en oeuvre les
compétences et l'ingénierie territoriale
et surtout accompagner au début du
projet parce que le début du projet
c'est presque là où c'est un peu clé
quoi c'est là où les choses se passent
donc il y a la clé d'entrée des
syndicats mixtes territoriaux il peut y
avoir une clé d'entrée des communautés
de communes parce que mieux harmoniser
mieux mobiliser l'ingénierie
territoriale c'est aussi l'ingénierie
locale et du coup on voit bien qu'il
faudrait presque demain un nouveau
métier on essaye de dire que le
sous-préfet peut
l'être mais ce nouveau métier c'est le
métier un peu du point d'accueil
d'information et d'orientation qui
permet à un moment donné de structurer
la notion de guichet et de structurer la
réponse
et ça c'est ces nouvelles fonctions
entre guillemets sont pas toujours
clairement identifiés quelle est la
personne
idoine qui analyse le besoin et va
organiser les réponses en termes
d'ingénierie d'accompagnement une vraie
question clé et donc j'aimerais bien
avoir vos remarques sur ces sujets là la
remarque de la notion du guichet
territorial qu'est-ce qui peut être
judicieux un syndicat mix de territoire
une communauté de communes puisque le
but du jeu les gens terminerai là c'est
de faire en sorte d'avoir une
méthodologie de mise en oeuvre qui soit
claire et une méthodologie de mise en
oeuvre qui permet vraiment de mutualiser
les compétences d'État départements
région ou autre en tant que tel ce que
j'appelle moi sous forme de groupement
de compétences j'aimerais bien avoir vos
réactions sur ces remarques et ses
propositions
merci Président Madame et Monsieur merci
beaucoup de votre intervention c'était
très intéressant de vous entendre tous
les deux vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre de points des choses qui selon
vous fonctionnent bien d'autres
peut-être un tout petit peu moins bien
vous madame vous avez évoqué notamment
l'accompagnement autour des fonds
européens que nos territoires
seraient en droit et je dirais même
intéressé de pouvoir par moment
bénéficier et vous disiez qu'il y avait
peut-être une forme de d'insuffisance à
ce niveau là donc ma première question
va porter autour de cela Monsieur Zabo
vous-même vous avez évoqué un autre
point plutôt négatif c'était une forme
de disparité entre
territoires d'un point de vue
bénéfice d'accompagnement de la part de
l'anct alors ma question est quand même
général c'est que aujourd'hui le budget
de fonctionnement de la SCT c'est
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
ce n'est pas
donc on peut très pertinemment se poser
la question de l'efficacité de
l'efficience et en réalité on voit aussi
qu'il y a des territoires le mien
notamment où nous avons en fait des
agences
d'accompagnement d'ingéniorités
territoriale je suis dans les Yvelines
et ça fonctionne bien on connaît mieux
cette agence là parmi nos élus que la
NTT pardon de lire mais je crois que
c'est aussi quelque chose qui doit nous
interpeller interpeller dans cette
période financièrement difficile pour
beaucoup de nombres de collectivités
donc ma question est en réalité
s'il n'y avait pas eu d'un et c'était si
on raisonnait nous c'est là on est très
attaché à la décentralisation vous le
savez bien donc
au fond j'ai l'impression qu'on se pose
la question c'est à dire qu'on avait
dans certains territoires du sur-mesure
aujourd'hui on fait du prêt-à-porter
avec une espèce de centralisation que
l'on souhaite peut-être appliquer à
travers des programmes que vous avez
évoqué l'un et l'autre à l'ensemble de
nos territoires donc pensez-vous
finalement que cette approche est
pertinente et est-ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas plutôt réorienter toutes cette
énergie tous ces fonds plus
spécifiquement vers les départements et
vers les territoires pour gagner en
efficience justement
[Musique]
merci est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions avant que je donne la parole à
nos invités pour répondre nos trois
collègues
je n'en vois pas et bien je vous donne
la parole qui commence mais un boulet
alors merci pour vos pour vos
interrogations très très riches alors
tout d'abord sur le rôle des comités de
coordination monsieur sénateur
il faut bien avouer que le bilan est
assez mitigé dans la plupart des
départements certainement parce que le
rôle de ces comités de coordination
n'est pas forcément très clairement
établie et nous on fait le parallèle
avec ce qui se passe au conseil
d'administration de la NCT c'est à dire
que c'est assez descendant comme logique
et il n'y a pas de débat sur le fond des
politiques menées par Hélène c'était si
on fait le parallèle avec ce qui est en
train de se passer côté Serena ils sont
en train de mettre en place un comité
qui là vraiment parle des sujets de fond
en parallèle de ce qui se passe au
conseil d'administration et ça ça nous
semblerait une piste assez intéressante
pour dupliquer ce modèle là côté à NCT
parce que au conseil d'administration de
la NCT on parle beaucoup du
fonctionnement de l'agence boutique
interne très peu de la mise en oeuvre
des politiques publiques de façon
opérationnelle et dans les territoires
dans les comités de coordination c'est
un peu la même chose c'est très
descendant c'est souvent une information
de ce que mène la nécessité dans les
territoires mais il n'y a pas de débat
de fond et ça ça nous semble assez assez
dommage donc pas forcément une
suppression de ces comités de
coordination mais plutôt une
clarification de leur rôle premier point
et deuxième point une réflexion un peu
plus globale sur toute la commitologie
départementale qui existe il y a
beaucoup de de comités divers et variés
à cette échelle départementale et ce qui
rend d'autant plus flou le rôle de cette
de ce comité de coordination
deuxième point sur l'organisation de
l'ingénierie alors on rejoint assez
globalement les propos qui ont été tenus
par Monsieur le Sénateur
il y a certaines le fait de rendre le
sous-préfet coordinateur de la NCT à
l'échelle de l'arrondissement on peut
certainement être une bonne chose dans
une logique de rapprochement etc mais
c'est pas ça qui changera
fondamentalement la donne
on a avant tout le besoin de coordonner
l'action des uns des autres aujourd'hui
il existe une diversité très
impressionnante d'acteurs au niveau
local et les transitions auxquelles nous
faisons face aujourd'hui et auquel on va
faire face dans les mois et années qui
viennent nécessitent une coordination
extrêmement étroite entre le local et le
National du côté de l'État on a un terme
de l'État entre l'État central l'état
des concentré première logique
d'articulation entre et les
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
entre la sphère publique et la sphère
privée il y a toute une animation d'un
écosystème à mettre en place et
l'ingénierie de notre point de vue elle
est manquante à ce niveau là c'est à
dire quand on parle d'animation de
projet notre point de vue c'est pas de
l'animation technique dont on a besoin
le on a par exemple céréma qui fait ça
qui fait ça très bien mais il nous
manque des plumes localement qui soit
capable de rédiger des axes communs des
objectifs communs de développement du
territoire ce qui nous permettrait de
parler de façon un peu plus apaisée de
façon certainement un peu plus politique
d'usage des adefe etc donc vraiment
cette animation de projet et de
coordination parce que vous l'avez vous
l'avez très justement dit on a besoin
d'une alliance entre tous ces acteurs là
les PTR peuvent être une forme
intéressante les communautés de communes
d'agglomération également métropole
aussi je pense qu'il faut pas que
rigidifier les échelles
laisser aux acteurs locaux le soin
définir ce qui sera le plus pertinent
dans certains cas on pourra même avoir
une combinaison d'échelle entre un pôle
métropolitain et des interco à l'échelle
infra- enfin bref on peut imaginer des
combinaisons extrêmement variées je
pense aussi on l'aura en l'occurrence ça
peut être ça peut être extrêmement riche
mais en tout cas on a besoin cet
animation et cette coordination des des
acteurs ça nous semble absolument
indispensables d'où l'intérêt encore une
fois j'insiste de relancer les contrats
de relance et de transition écologique
et surtout pas les supprimer ce n'est
pas parfait comme exercice mais ça
nécessite un changement de culture
tellement profond que ça ne pouvait pas
être parfait mais on avait fait quand
même beaucoup d'efforts en très peu de
temps les élus locaux se sont mobilisés
au service des projets de territoire ça
serait dommage d'y mettre fin et d'avoir
une animation qui colle avec ses
contrats nous semblerait nous semblerait
intéressantes et puis pour pour répondre
à madame la sénatrice enfin
qu'est-ce qui se passerait s'il n'y
avait pas la NCT c'est une très bonne
question parce que c'est quelque chose
qui commence à
émerger dans les dans les instances
d'intercommunalités de France
avec des élus qui commencent à se dire
pourquoi mais je crois que le sénateur
d'en-tête tout à l'heure en parler
est-ce qu'il ne vaut pas mieux avoir en
fait une enveloppe financière dédiée par
par collectivité à l'ingénierie
territoriale
évidemment qui manque de moyens sur les
territoires que ce soit pour les
collectivités les outils intercommunaux
ou pour les services de l'État j'ai en
mémoire je crois que c'était il y a un
an le rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
dit que en disant l'État a supprimé
11000 postes dans les territoires en
particulier 70% à l'échelle des
départements et en particulier sur
l'accompagnement au territoire et en
particulier sur les questions politiques
environnementales donc on est dans cette
lecture là à gérer nous ce qu'on entend
c'est que ça a été dit je crois tout à
l'heure par le directeur général de NCT
de mettre des moyens supplémentaires
nouveaux est-ce que c'est un changement
de cas parce que c'est une inversion de
tendance on n'en sait rien en tout cas
dans les prémices de ce qu'on a entendu
sur France ruralité on nous parle de la
création de son poste pour de
l'ingénierie donc à l'échelle
départementale ou pas c'est ça reste
encore à définir donc on voit bien qu'il
y a une prise de conscience que pour
faire tout ce qu'on a à faire il manque
des personnes des compétences et ça
renvoie la question sur le sujet
la question de la coordination et nous
on renvoie la question la densité
d'acteurs et si on vient sur les sujets
de la vie quotidienne de nos habitants
la question de la mobilité la question
de la santé ou on voit bien que la
question là de la densité de ce type
d'opérateur pour accompagner les
collectivités ou les outils
intercommunaux qui se posent ce type de
questions elle est quand même très
difficilement appréhendable et peut-être
plus que la question de la coordination
qui est par définition un souci
collectif de rationalité la question est
plutôt de la question de l'accessibilité
on est on a un projet on est quelque
part sur le territoire à qui on
s'adresse en premier et beaucoup ça a
été dit et je souscris tout à fait c'est
d'ailleurs la fonction du service qu'on
a créé c'est un CIO en fait c'est et moi
je veux pas oublier de citer dans cette
audition la plateforme est
territoire.gouv qui est un vrai outil
simple et unique et et
c'est très bien comme ça même si hélas
d'autres ont eu l'idée d'en créer aussi
et nous on travaille beaucoup là-dessus
parce que on les avait aidés au tout
début c'est une un incubateur de la NCT
en leur disant nous on a une exigence
par rapport à votre plateforme c'est
qu'il faut que à partir du moment où la
commune d'identifier une série d'outils
accessibles il faut qu'elle ait le nom
de la personne et le numéro de téléphone
c'est vrai que c'est l'incarnation
qu'elle soit 10 20 50 200 km il faut
qu'on ait la personne qui est en
capacité de nous faire faire le pas de
supplémentaire et là aussi je souscris à
l'idée que beaucoup de nos territoires
ruraux sont empêchés de démarrer des
projets par cette difficulté
d'identifier le bon interlocuteur et
donc plutôt que de coordonner parce que
encore une fois sur la question de la
santé ça va être la délit aujourd'hui
par exemple les délégués départementaux
des ARS on a un rapport extrêmement
variable selon les territoires sur la
question de la mobilité les compétences
sont peut-être à la région peut-être aux
E là aussi à qui s'adresse le maire etc
donc c'est plutôt cette question de
d'imbrication plus que de coordination
et de repérage et d'identification des
acteurs qui nous paraît
important de travailler est-ce que c'est
le rôle de la NT en l'occurrence dans la
déclinaison locale est-ce que c'est le
rôle du sous-préfet ou du ou du préfet à
limite peut nous importe si le
département il y a des il y a des
départements où historiquement l'Agence
départementale existe depuis des
décennies si elle fait ça bien mieux que
le préfet pourquoi
changer mais cette question là elle est
là aussi comme souvent d'ailleurs très
largement différenciée selon les selon
les territoires donc voilà
identification et accessibilité
effective dans le repérage de de des
personnes qui sont capables
d'accompagner les élus
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais rebondir sur ce que vient de
dire Madame boulet d'abord effectivement
pour dire je pense que le CRPE est un
élément absolument central pour les
prochaines années alors là on a eu un
rapport des inspections générales un peu
mitigé sur la première génération des
CRPE mais comme l'a dit madame vous
laisser aussi un peu la mise en oeuvre
donc il y a un moment
obligatoirement de calage mais je crois
que là on a un outil extrêmement
important et pour revenir sur cette
question du fonctionnement alors on a
une vision commune avec la DCF puisque
la DCF a défendu à l'époque notamment
quand c'est beaucoup mobilisé au Sénat
dans les années
2018-2020 cette dotation elle est
toujours sur la table et peut-être même
en discussion chez Christophe bechus ce
matin avec les réseaux de collectivités
territoriales mais je crois
qu'effectivement on a intérêt à préciser
et je crois que le Sénat en lien avec
les réseaux de collect c'est ce qu'on
fait ce matin peu encore préciser ces
propositions essayer de mieux définir ce
qui est de l'ordre finalement de
l'initiative du territoire et ce qui est
l'ordre de ce qu'on attend vraiment de
l'État or en fait avec la NCT on demande
à l'état d'aider sur des projets c'est
pas logique ça devrait être de
l'ingénierie territoriale y compris il
faut quand même se dire que avec la
transition écologique y compris Lausanne
l'efficacité énergétique la rénovation
tout ce qu'on veut c'est des dizaines de
milliers de projets qu'il va falloir
monter dans les prochains années et la
NCT n'aura jamais les moyens d'instruire
des dizaines de milliers de projets donc
le gros d'étranglement il va encore se
resserrer à l'inverse si l'état financé
une forme de DGF climat puisque c'est ça
là on aurait l'ingénierie qui
correspondrait à l'animation et on
aurait peut-être besoin d'une NCT qui
facilite les dialogues avec les
différents administrations l'Etat mais
qui soit plus réduite dans ses à ce
niveau là donc moi je crois que au
niveau du Sénat on a vraiment
approfondir la réflexion et à avancer
sur une proposition on peut reboter en
loi de finance on l'a déjà fait avec
Jean-François ils sont et Cristina
Navarre la dotation climat et je sens
quand même que l'État est plus ouvert à
la proposition qui a un certain nombre
d'années parce qu'il voit bien arriver
le mur des projets qu'il a mis lui-même
sur la table des dispositifs comme le
tiers financement qu'on a voté de porter
par Christophe bichu mais on n'a pas
l'ingénierie dans les petits territoires
pour aller chercher ce type de
financement donc je crois qu'on est dans
un moment clé et qu'effectivement ce
matin ça permet déjà de de passer un
premier message à à l'état et qu'à
l'inverse derrière si l'État va dans ce
sens là ça veut dire que ça sera aussi
une contractualisation sur résultat
notamment sur le PC aet qui est un
élément clé du CRT donc ça veut dire
aussi que les territoires accepteront
certainement d'aller plus loin sur une
contractualisation sur objectif avec
l'État donc c'est plus une réflexion
mais je voulais rebondir au propos de
Madame boulet mais ça fait tellement
longtemps encore plus dans le même sens
que évidemment il y a il y a un axe qui
ne se dément pas
je sais pas si ça amène une réponse à un
boulet peut-être une réaction
effectivement vous l'avez souligné à la
fin de votre intervention tous les
montages financiers qu'on est en train
d'imaginer aujourd'hui
vont nécessiter aussi une générique
financière complètement renouvelée et là
il y a un énorme travail à faire
évidemment le Sénat se mobilise d'ores
et déjà sur le financement de la
transition écologique mais il y a
vraiment un travail de fond et dans les
Territoires il y a vraiment des risques
de décrochage de certains territoires
parce que certains vont avoir une ligne
générique financière extrêmement
développée etc et sa faire et ils ont
même
l'imagination nécessaire pour pour
imaginer des montages dans la plupart
des territoires ça risque d'être
beaucoup plus compliqué et là il y a un
vrai rôle de pédagogie de mise en réseau
des territoires qui va être très très
important dans les dans les mois qui
viennent et ça arrive d'aller assez vite
parce que tout ce qui se passe autour de
l'économie mixte etc on voit qu'il y a
des territoires là qui ont pris le
virage de façon extrêmement rapide il
s'agirait pas qu'il y a un décrochage de
certains parce que la transition
écologique faut que ça emmène tout le
monde
y a-t-il d'autres questions
et bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions je vais lever les yeux je
voudrais
participer aussi à cet échange parce
qu'il est essentiel je pense que les
sujets qui sont évoqués sur la question
de la transition sur les virages qui
sont à faire nécessite que on revit on
revisite un certain nombre de nos
certitudes et je pense la question
de ces efforts là suppose que tout le
monde puisse agir et que tout le monde
est une une capacité à agir sur la
question de la transition ce qu'on
développe des fois justement ce matin
auprès de Christophe Béchu c'est que il
faut que ce soit et les communes et les
outils intercommunaux et donc ne pas
contraindre c'est pour ça que nous sur
les CRPE je j'ai pas réagi plutôt
là-dessus
ça sert à rien que ce soit un cadre
nouveau qui souvent localement a pas
forcément une plus forte notoriété que
la NCT auprès de certains maires et de
l'autre côté que ce soit un cadre qui
corset plutôt qu'il ne facilite et donc
ça nous là dessus on a une lecture un
peu plus comment dire
diversifier on va dire les choses
là-dessus par rapport à la nécessité de
contraindre notamment parce que de
manière très concrète à l'échelle locale
dans la première génération des CRPE on
s'est aperçu que par exemple les
secrétaires généraux discuter uniquement
les directeurs généraux de
d'intercommunalité pour hiérarchiser à
l'intérieur eux-mêmes savoir quels
étaient les projets communaux qui
étaient prioritaires c'était pas la
règle mais ça a été observé et ça fait
partie des déviances qu'il faut éviter
et donc est parallèlement sur la
question du financement il faut pas
sous-estimer aussi la diversité aussi de
l'appropriation par les maires de ces
enjeux-là y compris à l'échelle des
intercos et rentrer exclusivement par
l'interco quand vous avez des mers qui
ont envie et qui font des choses à
l'échelle communale depuis des décennies
il faut pas les dissuader de pouvoir
continuer et développer les choses
et donc sur les questions de dotation il
faudra que ce soit aussi une réflexion
qui aille à la fois sur la question de
la répartition desifères aujourd'hui les
conditions ne sont pas réglées pour
permettre une un développement des des
projets notamment sur l'éolien ou soit
ou le solaire dans les conditions
actuelles de la répartition desifers ça
c'est très clair sur la question de la
dotation biodiversité qui aujourd'hui
est un
tout petit outil par rapport à l'enjeu
qui qui nous qui est aussi devant nous
donc à la fois en volume et surtout en
superficie il va falloir que les choses
aient évoluent j'ai pas répondu tout à
l'heure pardon c'est Nicolay sur la
question des CLDC il y a la question de
la mise en ligne il y a la question de
faire la question du calendrier
c'est-à-dire que c'est arrivé de manière
extrêmement échelonnée entre la création
de l'anct et le dernier CLT secret il y
a quasiment eu deux ans donc on voit
bien que c'est pas un outil de de mise
en oeuvre de politique c'est
effectivement ça a été dit c'est un
outil d'information et c'est donc très
clairement insuffisant mais on pourrait
faire la critique aussi sur la question
du schéma des services publics où on ne
parle pas mobilité ou on ne parle pas
plein de sujets on ne parle pas de santé
alors que qui mieux que c'est de sujets
là font partie de la question des
services publics et je le vois moi je
veux terminé là-dessus sur l’imbrication
entre les différentes formes
d'ingénierie présentes la question
urbain rurale aussi on a travaillé on
travaille avec France urbaine sur cette
question de moi j'appelle ça la
péréquation technique beaucoup d'agences
d'Urba beaucoup de de métropole dispose
d'une ingénierie formidable comment
est-ce qu'on peut organiser des
coalitions pour que là où on en a besoin
on puisse faire appel à des de
l'ingénierie qui ne soient pas
exclusivement liés à des territoires
locaux ne pas sous-estimer aussi on l'a
vu dans un plusieurs programmes de
l'anct la difficulté que par exemple
d'associer la question et se rejoint la
question urbain orale la question de
comment est-ce qu'on donne envie à des
gens de d'aller travailler pour les
territoires européens quel que soit
d'ailleurs l'employeur que ce soit le
département l'état etc donc la question
la fluidité entre le monde universitaire
on l'a vu sur le programme des VTA par
exemple il y a eu un une absence de
rencontre opérationnelle entre une offre
et une demande et il très très peu
d'informations faites dans les
universités pour dire allez rendez-vous
utile au service des territoires et on a
eu beaucoup de mal c'est un peu le même
chose qu'on a sur les services civiques
à trouver des gens qui vont en face des
missions qu'on leur propose et ou à
l'inverse quand on avait des
propositions de mission le territoire
était pas forcément informé que il y
avait des jeunes qualifiés qui étaient
intéressés à ça et ça renvoie la
question malgré tout de la de la de la
rencontre entre cette offre et cette
demande il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont
envie de travailler aujourd'hui au
service de la transition au service des
territoires etc il y a pas forcément de
de linéarité de combinatoire là-dessus
et je pense ça peut être si on est sur
le sujet d'aujourd'hui sur la NCT un de
ces rôles aussi de stimuler ces rhizomes
et de stimuler ces connexions qui
aujourd'hui sont très largement
insuffisantes
merci je vais redonner la parole à Hervé
gilet qui veut compléter je vais essayer
d'être assez court mais je pense que là
on est sur le fond du sujet moi
personnellement donc ça mériterait sans
doute des échanges encore plus
approfondis pour pour aller un petit peu
plus loin parce que je j'écoute mes
chers Abou avec beaucoup d'attention et
je comprends sa position équilibrée
entre le respect de la collectivité à
titre individuel et en même temps son
inscription d'une manière plus
collective au travers des communautés de
communes ou des projets de territoire et
donc au niveau des méruaux on peut
l'entendre mais en même temps il faut
que ça soit bien structuré et bien
coordonné malgré tout parce que le
projet de territoire il reste quand même
la clé d'entrée majeure chacun doit
prendre sa part à l'échelle de chaque
collectivité et elle doit pas se faire
écraser ou ne pas avoir de difficultés à
mettre en oeuvre son projet si d'autres
essayent de tirer la couverture à eux
donc ça c'est des vraiment des questions
d'équilibre mais ces questions de fond
prenant dans tech là un peu envisagé
parce que dans le cadre RTE on va dire
même de la planification écologique
c'est là où il y a l'enjeu en fait et
l'enjeu au niveau des pcaet c'est des
pc-et territoire c'est pas des PC de
toute petite commune donc on doit bien
s'inscrire aussi dans ces stratégies là
quelque part ça veut dire que demain il
y aura sans doute des politiques de plus
en plus conditionnés à tous les niveaux
sans doute même à l'échelon communale
donc c'est comment on y rentre comment
on s'inscrit ensuite de l'échelon
communale dans une stratégie
territoriale et comment on crée les
conditions que l'ingénierie puisse se
mettre en place de manière en même temps
coopérative puisque comme vous l'avez
indiqué avec la métropoles de plus en
plus les contrats de coopération les
métropoles sur les aménités et sur le
fait d'aller chercher aussi les
compensations à l'extérieur qui peuvent
être de nature multiple en fait
nécessiteront bien sûr que ces
coopérations soient les plus lisibles
possibles aussi sur l'accompagnement des
projets sur les territoires mais pour
moi ça c'est vraiment le coeur du sujet
vraiment aujourd'hui et président ça
nous amènerait presque moi je le
souhaiterais presque un échange encore
plus approfondi sur le sujet
merci oui effectivement je suis pas sûr
que avec le temps qui nous imparti et
que ce sujet puisse être vraiment traité
on peut regarder effectivement ce genre
de sujet
moi je voudrais
vous remercier tous les deux mais un
boulet monsieur
parce que je sais que c'était pas facile
effectivement de pouvoir être à cette
audition
c'est qu'on a un peu bouscu les choses
j'ai eu votre président au téléphone je
sais que vous êtes beaucoup sollicité
dans les auditions et qu'effectivement
c'est pas c'est pas toujours simple de
de répondre favorablement mais moi je
vous remercie vraiment tous les deux
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
d'avoir répondu aux questions de nos de
nos collègues et puis vous voyez il y a
encore plein de sujets qu'on pourrait
évoquer pourra donc on vous resolicitera
mais on va peut-être un petit peu vous
laisser effectivement travailler parce
que vous avez aussi beaucoup d'activités
ça de vos structures
mais encore vraiment un très grand merci
de la part de tous les collègues de la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
pour votre disponibilité et votre
professionnalisme merci